AI Adventures
-Art, Science, and Tools of
Machine Learning
May 10, 2018.
8:30 a.m.
PT.
AI Adventures-Art, Science, and
Tools of Machine Learning.
May 10, 2018.
8:30 a.m. PT.
AI Adventures- Art, Science, and
Tools of Machine Learning
.
(captioner standing by)
(music)
.
>> YUFENG GUO: Good
morning.
(Applause).
>> YUFENG GUO: May name is
Yufeng.
I host a video series on YouTube
called AI Adventures, we explore
the art, science, and tools of
Machine Learning.  I wanted to
bring a little piece of
that here today in person, so
let's go
on an AI adventure together.
For the purposes of this
session, let's start with just a
short definition of Machine
Learning and use that to build
up kind of a workflow and get
into the tools.
We'll then use that today
to help
us see how we can solve Machine
Learning problems and see how we
can use that to
apply to your problems outside
of I/O.
And so we'll say that Machine
Learning is programming with
data, and we'll use that data to
create a system
or model which is trained to do
some
task, and we train this model,
very importantly, using data so
everything comes back to the
data.
So that's really the first step
of Machine Learning, gathering
your data.
It all centers and starts from
there.  Next, there is typically
some kind of preparation needed
of that data.  The raw data is
often not so suitable for use,
and so we need to prepare it a
little before it's ready for
Machine Learning.
Third, we'll need to choose a
model
we want to use, and then train
it up and
evaluate its performance, do
some fine tuning, and finally
make those predictions and do
those tasks.
So we'll go through each of
these seven steps in detail over
the course of this session.  So
first, let's see what question
we are trying to use our model
to address
in the first place.
We'll walk through kind of a
simple example dataset and go
through these
seven steps using the task to
categorize some data about
animals.  Okay.  We're going to
say, what kind of animal is this
based on some input data, is it
a bird, mammal, reptile, fish,
amphibian, bug,
vertebrae, one of these seven
types based on a variety of
stats about a given animal.
So our model will take in
this
data, this structured data, and
use that to try to make a
prediction, one of these seven
types of animals.
Now that we know what kind of
situation that we're modeling,
let's dive into each of these
steps in more detail.
First up is gathering data.
Just because we know what
problem we are trying to solve
for doesn't always mean that we
have the data needed to
solve it, and without data your
model is
going nowhere.
So ask yourself this, where does
my
data live and in what format,
and how can I get to it?
These are often times the early
stumbling blocks as we kind of
try to
use data to solve and address
our problems.
And perhaps you're actually in a
situation where you don't have
all the data that you need, and
you need to collect your own
data.  This is also a common use
case and you can get creative in
solving this problem by building
some systems for data
collection, perhaps you make it
a game.  One really interesting
example of this is Quick  Draw.
Quick Draw is an online game
that lets you draw a specific
picture and tries to predict
what you're drawing.
So it tells you to draw a
basketball or draw a boat.  It's
kind of fun and people like it,
and as a result the game has
generated
over 1 billion doodles of
hand-drawn images from around
the world and this dataset is
Open Sourced on GitHub and
there is actually an AI
Adventures episode that we just
put out if you want to learn
more about using this dataset
and playing with that.
Back to our steps, we've
gathered our data, so what's
next?  Well, we got to prepare
that data.
Data preparation could be its
own separate talk entirely, so
we'll just touch on a few
aspects here.
Exploring your data before you
do any kind of Machine Learning
can really help you understand
your data better, and this is
fundamental because it gives you
this intuition about your
dataset and can save you a ton
of time and
headache later on in the
process, and so I really
encourage folks to clean their
data, to look at the data and
kind of get some intuition
around it.
It helps you identify gaps and
you'll learn a lot about what
you're working with along the
way, maybe you'll learn you need
more data or certain pieces of
data you collected weren't so
useful afterall.
One toy I like to play
there to do this is called
facets, we'll take a little
brief detour and talk about
that.  Facets is a Open Sourced
data visualization tool from
Google Research and it can help
you get a better sense
of your data distribution.
Yes, there are lots of
tools that enable you to do very
similar things,
you can write out commands and
call functions, but this one
kind of puts it all in one place
and because it's a UI, you won't
forget to compute a particular
statistic or look into some
corner of the data because it's
all computed for you.  It just
shows up, and so you can just
kind of browse it.  And so here
we can see  Facets applied
to our dataset of these animals
from the  zoo, and most of them
are kind of 1s
and 0s datasets, does it brief,
does it have a tail, things
like,  that and so that's why we
see this kind of funny
distribution on 0 to  1, but a
lot of times with numerical
distributions you'll see
something far more interesting.
Now, let's move on to our
third step of Machine Learning,
choosing a model.  And we'll
discuss a little bit about
model selection, how we might go
about doing this using the least
effort possible, and first,
let's build an intuition around
what is happening when
a Machine Learning model is
working well.
So here we see how the model is
trying to divide up a region,
trying to say which side is blue
and which side is orange to
match the data, which are the
dots.  It's not the hardest
example in the world, right,
everything is kind of already
separated out, but let's look at
something a little more
interesting.  Here we see the
model struggle for a little bit
as it tries to find a way to
draw that enclosing circle
around the blue dots, and it's
really need to see that these
tools are available to you today
which are sophisticated enough
to
handle all of the minutia for
you so you don't really need to
worry about the details of how
it's getting about it, it's just
a matter of is it  achieving the
task, but it is fun to see.
Different models can model
different kinds of data and
different
degrees degrees of complexity,
there's what monoselection is
really about, it's about seeing
what model is the right fit for
your particular dataset and the
particular problem you're trying
to solve.
Now, concretely, what we're
going to use is use TensorFlow
to achieve this, right.  So
there is lots of talks about
TensorFlow here at I/O this year
so I
want rehash those bits, but
we'll see an example, perhaps,
of what is might look like to
use TensorFlow to kind of do
model selection to actually
write that code, especially if
you haven't had too much
hands-on experience with
TensorFlow, this may be kind of
a useful
look at just how accessible it
can be.
So this is an example of a
linear classifier.  It's similar
to the first animation we saw.
It's good for drawing a kind of
linear line between two kind of
spaces.  We can see it's pretty
straightforward, but what if we
had more complex data, right?
This one-line call, well it kind
of stays a one-line call when
you try to try it out on a
different model, so
we're going to replace this with
a Deep Neural Network and it
only takes a few small tweaks,
and in this case we just have to
add one additional argument
called hidden units, and this
defines the structure of our
network.
In this case, we have three
layers with 30, 20, and 10
neurons in them.  And so all we
needed to do is literally just
change the name, just replace
that text and add one argument.
You don't have to re replumb
your entire system and don't
have to delete everything and
start from scratch.  That's
really neat, and it's similar
for a lot of models you can try.
A lot of them just involve one
flip of the method call and you
can basically play around with
these different menu of choices.
And so in that paradigm, it
allows
you to not have to commit to a
model kind of beforehand.  You
can try one out, see how it
does, and then come back, so
these seven steps, you work
through it and can iterate back,
you can always go back and cycle
through.
And so that brings us to our
next step.  We've  gathered our
data, we've
prepared it, we've chosen a
model for now at least, and now
we can do the training.
Training gets a lot of
attention because in some ways
that's where the magic happens,
but in practice it's often very
straightforward.  You just let
it run and you wait.  So let's
take a look at what happens
during the training and then we
can see it in code.
Conceptually when training a
model we pass in our data and we
ask the model right away to try
to make a prediction.  But the
prediction will be pretty bad
because our model
has initiallyized randomly, but
we make this prediction and take
it and compare it to the true
answer, the correct answer that
we know.
We use that information to
update the
model, and so each time we go
through
and update the model with a new
piece of data as it works its
way through the training set, it
allows the model to get better
and better over time with each
training loop, so that's kind of
what the training process looks
like.
But in practice when you
actually
need to code it up, we take our
function, we've created the
model, and
we just call dot train on it,
it's literally one line.
You just need to provide it a
function that gives it the
training data inputs and that's
it.  It's one line.  And so once
the training completes, you run
this function and you go off and
you grab a sandwich and you come
back and it's time to do
evaluation.  We got to evaluate
our models to see how accurate
it is, see if it's doing a
good job of performing its
primary task.
So we can show it some examples
of things that we know the
correct answers to, and the
model did not see those
questions in training.  It
didn't see that data in
training, so we use this
evaluation data that we set
aside to measure the performance
of
our model, and conceptually it
looks very similar to training,
right.  It's still this same
shape, but the important
difference is that there is no
arrow at the top, it's not a
closed loop.
The model does not get updated
once we check its prediction
results, and so if we did update
the model, then it would be no
different than training and we'd
be essentially cheating, right.
So the evaluation data is
kind of precious in that way.
We don't use it to update the
model.
We hold it aside and we reserve
it for
evaluating the performance of
our model.
In code it's just as simple as
everything else we've seen.
We just call dot evaluate.  You
want to evaluate, you call.
evaluate.  Notice we're passing
in evaluation  data, right, it's
not the training data, and if we
were using the training data,
let's say we copy that line down
and swopped out train for
evaluate and we forgot to change
the data source, now we're
evaluating the performance of
our
model using the training data
and that would be a big mistake
because the model
has optimized itself for the
training
data, and so if you evaluate
using that
same data what happens is you've
misrepresented the true
performance of your model and it
will likely perform
poorly on  real  real-world data
once you deploy it since its
never seen and you never
measured how it does with
previously unseen data.
So this brings us to our next
point.  How can we actually
improve our model then?  We ran
the training and did the thing
and ran evaluation, now what?
Do we run training some more?
How can we tweak it further?  We
could always swop out for a new
model, but what if we decided on
this model but we want to
improve it as is?  This is where
hyperparameter tuning comes in.
These models have parameters of
their own, but what value should
we use?  How do we pick them?
Much like how you can try
out different models, you can
also try out lots of different
model parameters.  This process
called hyperparameter tuning, in
some ways, still remains a
active area of research, but
that doesn't mean that you can't
take advantage of it.
Conceptually, you would take our
training and instead of just
training one model, we'll tweak
that model and
create a couple of different
variants, and so we'll run
training on different variants
of the same underlying model but
with different model parameters
and see how that  affects our
accuracy.  So we'll train and
evaluate all of these different
variants of the same or similar
models and then see which one
performs best.  That's how it
informs our parameter choice.
But you see, a lot of that is
experimental.
You got to try them to see what
works,
so you might have to break out
your four loop.
And so yeah, the task of
choosing
good  hyperparameters is
something
perhaps that you've intuited
this, you could probably turn
into a Machine Learning problem
itself, optimizing the
parameters you're using for
Machine Learning, but we'll have
to save that for another talk.
All right.  So we've
gathered the data, we've
prepared it, chosen a model and
trained
it, evaluated the data, and we
tuned the hyperparameters.  At
long last we've reached our last
step, making those predictions.
This is the whole point of
training out the model in the
first place, right.  It wasn't
just to get a really good
accuracy or to create heat on
our server.  It was to actually
do something useful with it.
And so making predictions, we
take the model and we deploy it
somewhere or kind
of isolate it out, and we can
show the
model some data that it hasn't
been trained on and then see
what kind of outputs it
predicts.
And so that's
our our seven steps, conceptual
seven steps.  Let's see what
happens in practice, look at the
tooling side and figure out what
you use besides TensorFlow and
how you might actually achieve
the seven steps.  So we're going
to go and look at some code, and
in particular I'll feature a
couple of tools to get hands on
with and I'll point you to some
additional resources as well.
First up is a tool called
codelab.
If you've ever worked with any
sort of notebook environment or
repple on the web before, this
is basically a way to
run Python in the browser, but
not just run Python.  It's a
whole  notebook environment.
You can put Mark down.  The code
actually executes, and because
it's hosted essentially on
Google Drive, you can share it
with other people.
So let's switch over to the demo
and I can show you what is looks
like to use Codelab.
So here we see and I've loaded
up Codelab and we can run
various commands, right, all the
things that we would expect.
So let's see, we're still
connected and in Codelab because
it's a notebook environment, you
have to upload your own files
and it connects to the Internet
so you can also authenticate and
pull things down, but in my case
I have the dataset loaded on the
machine so we can download that.
I've got pandas loaded here so
we can take a lock at your data
decision  set, as promised it's
a bunch of animals and
statistics, and at the very end
there is a class type.
And so Codelab really lets you
just
execute the code on the screen
in, well, in realtime.  And
moreover, because it's all
hosted
on Google Drive I don't have to
spin up
any machines in the background,
it just works seamlessly.  You
can put comments in and share
your
work with others, and -- there
we go, and do collaborative
research or just
work in general, so that's
really neat.
And so let's see, I think we
have some time so let's actually
walk through a little bit of
kind of what I've ended up doing
here.  We took our data and what
I'm doing is
shuffling it and then splitting
the data.  We had a whole
dataset, right.
This whole dataset happens to
just be 101 different animal, so
it's probably the smallest
dataset that I've probably come
across, but you still need to do
the same types of best
practices.
In this case I've taken it and
split
it into training and evaluation
data because if I use all 101 to
do training, what am I going to
do to evaluate my model?
So we'll split it, and in this
case
I chose a fraction of 60% and
40%, but that ratio can be
adjusted, and so we
can see we have our training
data, all 60 values, and then we
have our evaluation data below.
And I do a little bit of
preprocessing so this is the
processing
your data bit, and notably the
last column of the dataset is
the label, it
is the answer one through seven
of what the correct type of
animal it is, reptile,
amphibian, mammal, et cetera.
The problem is the labels
go from one to seven and I need
them to be zero through six in
this particular case, so I shift
it by one by subtracting one and
that's it.  So pretty simple
preprocessing, is and I would
expect that a bigger dataset
perhaps would do more things.
And so we can see that our data
apparently I didn't make this
run.  Run.  Always run your
code.
And our input function here is
pretty straightforward.
It takes our raw data, and if we
want it to be shuffled we can
call shuffle on our dataset and
I just let it repeat and
batch into
chunks as needed and it will fit
into the training.  I believe
there was a talk on this
specifically earlier at I/O so
if you
missed that you can catch the
recording or roll back the
livestream.
So we have our dataset or our
input function.  I think I
forgot to run this cell again.
And this is a little cell I have
here
to just kind of try out my input
function, make sure it's
working, always good to test
things.  We can see my input
function is indeed returning all
of the data of each type of the
feathers, whether it's eggs,
whether it's airborn, does it
have a backbone, things like
that.
So each kind of these arrays
represent a batch of data.  I
was also playing around with
this to check out the unique
values for each
column just to make sure, most
are 1s and 0s, and but there are
a couple that are strange, for
example, there are
animals with five legs
apparently so not
all datasets are perfect.
TensorFlow uses this notion
of feature columns to represent
the incoming data.  Models are
pretty generic, and so by using
feature columns it allows you to
customize it for your particular
dataset.
In our case, I just loop over
all the columns, all 17 of them
which happen to be numeric and
set that as numeric, so it's
really just a configuration to
let TensorFlow know how many
columns and of what type are
coming in.
So we'll run that and if things
break it's because I forgot to
run the cell, so yell at me if
that happens.  And so here is
that line that we saw before,
right, with the creating a
model, so here we'll create a
linear classifier and pull in
those feature columns and say
that there are seven different
classes, seven different
possible values for the animals.
And I've combined the train and
ee
value, train and evaluate calls
in as a function for convenience
so they both run together.  I
want to run the training on the
training data and evaluation on
the evaluation data, so wrapping
this together helps make sure
you don't introduce bugs as you
re-run cells as you go along.
So let's say we run the linear
model and we'll just let that
churn, and
so this is all backed by Google
Servers
and apparently it is taking its
sweet time.
While it's do that -- well this
one is done, so we got 90%,
which is like okay, right.
There were only 100 rows, we
took 60 for training and used 40
for evaluation, so it's not the
most reliable metric.  The idea
here is the tooling is there,
the code is there, and you
should replace this with your
own data which will be much
better than this dataset and get
awesome results.
So as promised, the Deep
Neural Network is very similar.
It's literally the same as
before but I replaced it with
hidden units.  I guess there is
one notable difference, is that
I do take the old feature
columns that we had from before
and we wrap it in an indicator
column,
so that's just a space to put
the linear networks data into a
way that the Deep Neural Network
can represent, so it's a little
bit out of scope for this talk,
but it's an adjustment just for
Deep Neural Networks that linear
networks don't have to deal
with.
So we'll let that get created.
Oops, just created a new cell.
So I guess that's also a good
thing to
show off here, so we can very
easily create, you know, code
blocks and cell blocks in
between and can you have all
sorts of great editing kind of
abilities
here, and you can turn it into
-- and you execute the cell and
it will be there.
So with the deep network, I
forgot if I ran this.  Maybe
we'll run it again.
We can also like push the model
further, right.
The percentages here are
sometimes wonky because they are
-- there is only 40 values in
the evaluation data and this is
effectively, you know, something
over 40 is getting it right and
the other ones are wrong, so in
this case it
looks like that 10%, probably
four are wrong or three or four
are incorrect.  So let's make
some predictions and see what
got missed.
TensorFlow also has a.
predict function so you can pass
in, I just took evaluation data
and sliced out a couple of
examples to take a look at.  We
can see here that when we do
that you get, you know, you get
the prediction and the correct
answer, so in this case those
five that I arbitrarily chose
happened to work out but what if
we wanted to see the exact ones
that we got wrong?  This was a
little experiment I ran just
because I was curious, you know,
which ones were the linear
network getting wrong and which
were the deep network getting
wrong?  In this case they're
different, right.
They got the same number of
incorrect predictions.  They all
had four wrong, but they're
actually different examples.  So
this would be a opportunity to
dig in further and play around
with that.
One final thing I'll adhere
is that
Codelab or Colaboratory has GPU
support
and so you can toggle on GPU so
if you have big datasets and
fancy models and you want to
access that kind of stuff, go
and get that GPU.
So let's switch back to the
slides
briefly and take a look at
another tool.
Aside from Codelab there is
another tool that we have that
is very similar and it's also
notebook based.  You might have
heard of it.  It's called
Kaggle.
And while Kaggle is most known
for its
competitions or discussion
forums and datasets, it also has
a feature called kernels and
kernels is really just a
fancy name for notebook, and the
kernels look something like
this, this might
start to look familiar from
Codelab except it's blue.
Kernels is different in a couple
of subtle ways.  Firstly, I want
to -- let's just
switch over to the demo for
Kaggle kernels and we'll see
what that looks like.  How is
that.
So I took the notebook that we
had
earlier in Codelab and I
downloaded the notebook itself
as a notebook file.  Since
Kaggle has datasets we actually
have a zoo animal classification
dataset, how convenient that I
chose the exact dataset that
already exists on Kaggle, right.
And so we can click new
kernel, and I'm going to choose
notebook, and Kaggle kernel is
not only run in Python but you
can also choose to run them in R
for those of you who prefer R.
And what I can do is I can
actually
upload a notebook of -- well,
first I need to download that
notebook, so let's do that.
So from Codelab
we will download -- this is what
I get for zooming in a lot.
We download the notebook and
then once
it's downloaded we can upload
that notebook back into Kaggle
kernels and so boom, we have
that same notebook now in
kernels.
There is one small tweak.
Because we had to upload a file
from
the local drive for Codelab
we're going to get rid of that.
And the only other tweak is that
in Kaggle kernels the data lives
in one directory up called
Input.  So if I run the first
cell and then we'll work our way
down, we'll see that the data
lives in input and it's the same
kind of thing.  And since we
already see the rest of the
notebook, it's literally the
same thing.
What is interesting though
is that
in the kernels, we can -- let's
see.  Let's give it a name.
We can commit that notebook, and
what Kaggle kernels does is it
will run your
notebook in a new fresh
environment, separate from the
session that you're in.  This
will generate a notebook with
all the outputs that we've been
seeing in a
kind of nice view-only format,
which is really useful for
sharing because what if you want
to share your notebook as
well as how it was executed to
others?  You want reproducible
notebooks so that's kind of what
we see here.
We ran the notebook, it's done,
and we can view that snapshot,
so it's kind of like a GitHub
model of like you can commit
versions of your notebook.
And so by default, your
notebooks are private and we can
see here that things ran.  The
outputs are shown, and I didn't
have to go through and run these
one by one, right.  If I ran
these cells out of order,
manually earlier to yield my
results, running them top to
bottom like this
will help catch those kind of
bugs that would make it hard to
reproduce my performance down
the road when I come back to
this next week or next month.
And if you share your
notebooks, you can then fork
them, you can fork them and you
can also get others to fork your
notebooks as well as add
collaborators to your
notebooks, so you can add users
to join you on the same notebook
rather than just forking them.
So there is a lot of great
collaboration models across
Colaboratory and Kaggle
depending on your particular
use case, and I guess it would
be good
to also just briefly mention
that like
Codelab, we can also enable GPUs
in Kaggle kernels as well, so
don't let that be a deciding
factor for you.
So that's Kaggle kernels, and
let's switch back over to the
slides and talk about just a few
other kind of little tools and
tips and tricks before we kind
of wrap things up.
And if we could switch back to
the slides.  Awesome.
So let's say you don't want
notebooks.  Let's say you try
Notebooks and they just weren't
for you or you have a bigger
workload.
You need to run a long running
job, it's got to run for hours,
or you have a really big dataset
and it doesn't fit in Kaggle
kernels or doesn't fit on your
local directory so you're not
going to upload it to Drive
manually.
Then you can use something like
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
where you
can kick off a job to run a long
running job that maybe runs
across a set of distributed
machines, all of them
potentially with GPUs attached.
And once you're done, you might
want to serve your model,
right.
You want to make those
prediction, but perhaps you want
to do it at scale.  You're
building a app, you train a
model, and you want to rest a
REST endpoint that can serve
predictions to the world, and so
Machine Learning
Engine also includes a
auto-scaling prediction service.
You can literally just take your
TensorFlow model, give it a
name, and be done.  Literally,
point to the file and give it a
name.  There aren't any other
steps because you can't do
anything else in terms of
creating a model to serve, which
is really neat.
And if you're working with
things
like sigh kit learn or XGBoost
and you want to use those as
well, we'll take those too, and
then you don't have to
deal with the ops aspect of
Machine Learning, play with the
data, tweak your model, train
it, and deploy with ease.
And I think most -- not most --
but many of you are also perhaps
aware of the Machine Learning
APIs that are also available.
These are pre-trained APIs for
doing various tasks.  They're a
little more canned, right.  You
don't provide your own data, but
it does mean that everything
just works out of the box.  You
need  something -- you need a
picture to be turned into a
description, you need audio to
be turned into text, it just
works so that's kind of nice,
but the limitations, of course,
are that you can't customize it
for your specific use case.
That is still something that
you'll have to just wait a
little bit longer for, with the
one notable exception of
Vision, so the Auto ML Vision is
available right now in alpha so
you can apply for that and
supply your own datasets to
train and customize your own
Vision API, so that's kind of
like a neat side tangent.
The animations that we saw
earlier
that I showed with the orange
and blue dots came from the
TensorFlow  Playground.  So if
you want to play around with a
neural network in your browser
and just like toggle things on
and off and mess around, head
over to playground.tensorFlow.
org and you can do that right
there.
And don't worry, you can't break
it.  It's just through your
browser.  You can only break
your own machine.  (Laughing).
And so what's next?
The code that we just saw, I
made it
public and it's on Kaggle at
Kaggle.
com/ Kaggle.
com/yufengg/zoo-demo.  If you
want to learn more about
TensorFlow head to TensorFlow.
org and there is a Machine
Learning crash course Google
released recently, so if you
want to really dive into the
concepts of Machine Learning and
go further than what we've
talked about today, head over
there because there is basically
a whole curriculum of videos and
kind of assignments that you can
do and really build up your
Machine Learning knowledge.
Finally, if you're interested in
doing Machine Learning in the
Cloud you
can head over to the Cloud Dome,
the
white tent next to the Google
Assistant Dome or head to Cloud.
google.
com/ML.  I host a video series
by the same name of thissation.
AI Adventures, we explore some
interesting nugget in each
episode about Machine Learning
and try to do some hands
on-demos once in a while and do
some interviews with interesting
folks.
So hopefully you'll check
it out and subscribe.
So I want to thank you for
joining me in this  session, and
we really -- you know, I really
appreciate feedback on the
session, the information, so
please head on over to the
schedule and you can log in and
give some feedback.  Thanks a
lot.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits.  We'll be
making room for those who have
registered for the next session.
If you've registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
May 10, 2018
9:30 a.m.
PT
How to Kotlin
The
>> At this time please find
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> Hello and good morning! It
seems like the mic is not on.
Hello?  Hello?
(Applause)
>> Hello. The mic is not
on.
Hello!  This is better.  Thank
you!  Thanks for being here this
morning.
My name is James and I'm part of
the Kotlin team at Google.
Today I have the pleasure of
introducing a very special guest
from Jetbrains who really
requires no introduction.
Now, all of you know that Kotlin
is
now one of the most loved
programming languages in the
world.
(Applause)
And at Google I/O it's very rare
for us to have external
speakers, but this
person was here last year and we
invited him back because he
couldn't think of
anybody else to better teach
Kotlin other than one of the
people who
invented it, so please help me
welcome
the Lead  Language Designer for
Kotlin.  Andrey Breslav
(Applause)
>> ANDREA FOEGLER: Thank you,
James.
>> Hello, everybody. I've
very glad to be here.  Today I'm
going to talk about what can it
be, Kotlin, I guess, and I'm
really going to do a live demo
so please bring my demo on.
So the reason why I have this
horrible code in the slides is
that we
are all learning and our old
habits sometimes get in the way,
so I'll be
presenting today on the topic of
how you get out of your Java
habits and get to your Kotlin
habits, so we all come from
different backrounds, of course,
and
many of us started with the Java
Programming Language and built
up our knowledge of  programming
through this, and so we remember
many things.  The thing is
Kotlin has been inspired
by many languages complu
languages including the Java
Programming Language, so many of
the
constructs in Java will work in
Kotlin and you can get your job
done in this way, but in many
cases it can be improved
dramatically.
This particular example is
about declaring classes, and can
you see here that I have a
Kotlin class on the left and a
Java class on the right and they
look very similar, but this is
definitely not how we write
Kotlin code.  What you're
actually supposed to do is like
remove all the unnecessary
stuff.
What I have to say here is one
class, that's it, I can try to
transform by hand, but I
actually want to show off a
nice tool and simply copy and
paste the code from the Java
site to Kotlin site
and so it will use the Java to
Kotlin converter built in and do
it for me, so boom, there it is
a single line that's
actually all you needed --
(Applause).
-- to declare one class and two
properties, and that's it.  All
I have here is a class with a
primary constructer, so it has
two parameters and both of them
are properties and that's all we
wanted to say.
So this is one of the things
that
demonstrates how cheap declaring
classes is in Kotlin, and there
is a consequence to this.  So
look at this code.  Here it's
obviously not how you're
supposed to write code in any
language, actually.  I wanted to
parse a full name into a first
name and last name, and so
that's what I'm doing  here, but
how do I pack
the results for the function?  I
don't have a way of returning
two things from a function.  I
have to put it into one object,
and
I'm using a list here and then
awkwardly taking out one and the
other to make a first name and
last name.  Don't do this in any
language.
But there is a kind of
psychological reason to doing
there, at least in our old
habits because declaring classes
is expensive, right.  You have
to create a new file, put a lot
of code in it, it's kind of
awkward.  But in Kotlin you
don't have to do this.
All you need to say is my class
fullname with first and last
names as
properties, and then all I need
to do
here is just return that, right.
So my full name, here it goes,
and
now instead of indices I can say
first
and last right here so that's
the idea.  Classes being cheap
is not only saving you time at
the declaration site, but it's
saving you mental effort.  You
can represent your multiple
return as a class and you
doesn't cost you anything.
So around this you see that my
equals doesn't work, obviously,
because that's
a single line class and so now
I'll go
to
declare equal there and then
hash there but really I don't
need to do this in Kotlin
because you probably know there
is something called data
classes, right, who knows data
classes?  Many people.  Good.
So you know that I simply put
this single keyword there and it
generates many things for me,
equals,  hashcode, string, and
many other convenient methods,
so that's it.  Change your mind
about how expensive a class  is.
You can use it easily in all of
your abstractions.
So more or less done with the
warmup, so let's look at
something else, properties.
So we talked about classes,
we'll go through  properties and
then go over to functions.
So here is a property done the
way you shouldn't do it in
Kotlin, again, and so the
properties I showed you before
were
kind of  one-liners were both is
trivial.  If you want a custom
setter you definitely don't
define functions for that.
You have your syntax as you
probably know, if you know data
classes you know
that, and so inside you have
field to write to your backend
storage, but that's it.  You
don't need to introduce extra
names and anything else, so
that's straightforward, right.
But then look at this code.
So here is already some sensible
logic.  I have two properties
and one of them
is private and nullable and
mutable, and on my first access
I'm checking if that's now and
then I compute a value
and write into it and then I
output return from my getter.
So what is it?  It's a lazy
property, right.
I personally wrote dozens and
dozens of those in Java and many
other
languages so I got kind of bored
by that and that's why Kotlin
has delegation for property, so
delegated properties let
you get a read of all the
reputation of this lazy  logic.
All you care about is this
expression here, so let's just
do it.
Implement my property by just
lazy of
all this.  This is it.  So what
I'm having now, I'm saying
that my property is not simply
simply initiallyized by
something but delegated to this
lazy thing here and upon first
access this lambda will be
executed and the rest will be
stored by the library, so lazy
is not a language construct, but
it's just a library function.
You can define your own, and the
library provides you with many
other things.
The takeaway here is that if you
have a common kind of property
like observable, for example,
when you need to be notified
that something was modified, use
a library or write your own.
So here delegates.
observable does the job from the
library, but if you like you
don't have
to write code like this when you
have one property and then the
other property and the other
doing the same thing over and
over again.
All you need to do is this,
actually,
declare a single class that
encapsulates the logic of your
property like your
generic getter and generic
setter and that's it.
Now you can simply refer to this
class in many properties and get
your business
logic database access, all kinds
of validation, anything you like
can be extracted as a library
and then reused across your
project.  Does that make sense?
Who uses this already?
So many people, you actually
should.  I'm sure you can
benefit from this.
Okay.  So this is more or
less it about properties and now
let's get to functions.
Functions are very important,
right.
So again, this is very horrible
code.  Don't try code like this
in Kotlin, please.  This is very
much inspired by our habits in
the Java programming language.
When you have to put everything
into a class, right.
So string, does your project has
its
own string class, if it doesn't
it's just a very new project,
right?
(laughter).
So any of my projects have them,
but the thing is in Kotlin it's
a little different.  You don't
have to use a class.  First of
all, a Kotlin class, they don't
have statics so to use these
functions from this class you
have to say string into
parentheses which makes a new
object, right.  I don't want a
new object every time, I want it
like this, so I turn this class
into an object.  It's a little
bit of an improvement in my
insanity, right, so I was
creating an object every time I
wanted to call a function,
that's crazy.
But really in Kotlin, I don't
need any enclosing container at
all because I have top-level
functions.
So this may seem obvious, like
functions, what are they?
They're just declarations,
right?  But some  languages, you
know, have them all in classes
and many people learned this and
rely on this.  So this is a lot
more of a Kotlin way,
but it's still not great in
terms of what you can achieve
with Kotlin because here you
have two overloads, right.
So getfirstword is supposed to
parse a string, find a space and
take the first word returned,
right.  But what if the
separator is not a
space but a comma or something,
so here is a more full featured
version and this is how you'll
call it actually in most
contexts, right.
So what I wanted to express
here is just a default value.
In Java we are used to using
overloads for this, and also
some people use
nullable parameters like tasks
and null here and I'll give you
a default value.  Don't do this
in Kotlin.  You don't need to.
All you need to do, actually, is
simply specify your default.  My
default is space here, and
that's it.  All right.  So there
is no need to emulate defaults.
They are built into the
language.
And same for when you have many,
many default parameters with
different
values like multiple Boolean and
so on and so forth, you can just
use named parameter syntax to
express which you actually need
and all the rest will be used by
default.  So this makes
functions fewer in the first
place, and then a lot more
expressive.
Okay.  Good with functions,
right?
Well, actually, this is kind of
-- this function is kind of
midway between
like the Kotlin style and the
Java style because it's actually
working on strengths, right.
Very much a good idea to put
this into a string class -- oh,
it's not because the string
class is not controlled by
you and we can put everything
into the string class and if you
really want to keep the string
API minimal, so what I would
really like to do is something
like this.
Where I can say my string
getfirstword and that's it.
Right.  So it looks like a
method, it's called an extension
function, actually.  It's not
sitting in a string class.  I
didn't go into the  JDK and
alter
the class I can control, but
still it works like this.
So this is a mechanism you can
use.  I'll do it manually to
illustrate how it works here.
So I have a receiver, I've typed
string, now I don't need this
parameter
anymore, and I can say that this
here
and use my "this" here or omit
"this" on the left-hand side so
now I'll be able to use it this
way.  Make sense?
Ky
I can do the same with a
property, actually it would be
very nice to do it this way.
Just have first word as a
property name, and you can have
an extension "property," but of
course there will be no
customization for the separator,
but otherwise you're good to go.
Yep.  I'll just need to put a
space here.  And that's it.
So extension functions,
extension properties, it's
actually very important
idea, it's not only just salines
convenience.  It allows you to
keep your classes very minimal.
Look at the string class in
Kotlin.  It's only five methods.
If you can compare that to Java
it's screens and screens of
declarations, so
you can keep your API minimal
and all
the utility functions can be
extensions, and certain
different libraries can be
modular like this and that's a
very important tool for
designing APIs.
Do you have questions?  Okay.  I
couldn't take them anyway.
(laughter).
Okay.  Now, let's have a
look at this.  Here I'm doing
something very typical
and pro verse
traversing a hierarchy,
containers and leaf elements,
and I want to extract all the
text from this hierarchy.
Pretty straightforward.
So my classes are three lines of
code.  Not much, there is an
element, a
container, and with the list of
children there is text.
Now I'm traversing this so I'm
using extensions function,
top-level functions, everything
as I told you, and so all right
but I don't like this code.
Why don't I like it?
Here to traverse the hierarchy I
need recursion so I need to pass
the string builder down the
stack and add to it as I'm going
down the tree.  But then I end
up with a top-level function
that's only needed by this one
here, right, so this one is not
really anywhere but inside this
function, so what I'd really
like to do is just put
it inside
, just go here and make it a
local function.
So again, it's just expressing
that nobody else needs this.
You don't need private helpers
anymore or look for local
helpers.  It can be improved a
little bit and you can actually
make use of closure, so
I can create my string builder
right here and get rid of all of
this so I
don't need to return or take
parameters here.
All I need here is to use
whatever is declared above.
And then I just do extract text
of
e right here and return string
builder to string.  I'm sorry,
that's an extension function,
right.
No, sorry.  Yeah.  So here is
how it goes.  Like, you can turn
something into a local function
and a leverage closure, so this
variable is declared outside my
function, it's not accessible to
anyone
outside the outer, and I'm using
here and that's it.
Now, local functions, extension
functions, deep level functions,
default parameters use these,
they will make your code nicer.
Now, let's look at what's
still there.  You see gray code?
Gray code is useless.  The ID in
the compiler show you that
something is not needed there
and it actually isn't.  This is
redundant because we have this
extract  here, right, so you
simply can remove this.  I don't
know if you see it -- oh, yeah
you do, but the text variable
has gone green.  Why it's green?
Because the compiler can figure
out the cast for you.  It's
actually much safer.  It's not
only convenient, but I'm really
annoyed at my  casts all over
the place, right.
I know it's text, why don't you
know?
Well, now it knows, and actually
you don't need this variable
either because
it's the only usage, right.  The
same thing here and then my
container can be in line as
well, and so
here it is.
Smart cast, makes your code
safer and more concise, and
actually it makes all the casts
that are still in your program
meaningful, so when you see an
as operator in Kotlin now you
know it means something, it's
not just a useless
complement to the is check
above.
Also, this thing here is kind of
stupid because what I'm doing is
applying the same function for
everything as a single function,
so what I want to do is
something like this.
It's a little bit nicer looking.
And then let's look at what we
have.  We're  traversing
hierarchy, I have my leaves, I
have my  containers, and that's
what I want to express, right?
I'm checking different case, so
to do
that it's a lot nicer to use a
"when" statement, so when can
switch in types right here, but
there is an annoying thing about
it, and it's again coming
from my old habits on declaring
at close hierarchy I have only
containers and text and I don't
have anything else, right.
Now I have this pretty annoying
"else case" right here.  The
compiler has no idea.  I don't
have anything but continues and
text.
It's just an abstract text and I
have some cases there.  You can
actually express this in Kotlin
with sealed.  I can have a seal
class which means all the
subclasses are known, you can
declare them outside of this
file, and
this way the ID and compiler
know this "else" is useless.
We went from almost two screens
of code to less than one, simply
applying the idiom it's of
Kotlin to this code.  Do you
have questions?
I'm sorry.  (Laughing).
All right.
So now let's just continue with
this
exercise and look at some more
examples of expressions that are
written like with old habits in
mind and we'll try to
transform them into something
better.  So first thing that
really stands out here is Var.
I can't say never use Var.
Vars are useful mutable
variables, can
be used for many nice things,
but it's kind of discouraged.
If you need a  Var, you need a
very good reason.
Here is now a good reason using
a Val, definitely.  Let's look
at these three.  It's
repetition.  Repetition is ugly,
repetition is  errorprone,
especially if this was not a
single name but many things
chained, so I would like to get
rid of this repetition.
What I can do is say with ex --
does anybody remember Pascal?
Anyone?  Good.  Good.  I started
in Pascal almost.
So it hid this thing which is a
building construct, and in
Kotlin it's a function and we
can use it and here we can get
rid of all the ex things here.
Just like this.  And now it
looks even more stupid, right.
I'm just  assigning to the same
variables, don't do that.
Okay.
So now I have a printline with
string plus some things, string
plus some things, string plus
some things.  It's awkward.
Most languages now have string
interpolation and Kotlin has
that as well, so what you
actually need here is this.
Okay.
Done with this one.  Import
things into your scope with
"with" use string interpolation,
it's nice.
Now here I'm creating a map, the
old way.  I can kind of make it
a little nicer
like this by using my operators,
which it's really much nicer if
I just use a builder function,
so what I can do here
is replace
my things with pairs -- oh --
not pairs, but pair.  I'm sorry,
typing when talking is
difficult.
Yeah, so a map can be
constructed of pairs, right.  A
map is only a set of pairs from
key to value, but actually pairs
are kind of
redundant in this so we're
usually using the to function.
It's not a built in operator but
just a library function here and
this is how you create a map.
When you want to traverse the
map, you
can say here key, and value, and
just a
few variables like this which
makes four
loops a lot more concise.
This example of code with my
"if" statement is something I
really hate about my code in
Java because it's like
these assignments here, they all
fall
apart so easily, so I really
like to do
things like this in Kotlin -- so
if -- and many other things are
actually expressions.  This is
something pretty unfamiliar for
this C language family.  We're
used to dividing our code into
statements and  expresses,
right.  Statements are things
that have effects and
expressions are things that have
value, so you assign expressions
to variables and write
statements to assign things to
things.
So Kotlin is halfway between
this
procedural tradition and
functional tradition but has a
lot more expressions than you're
used to in other languages.  You
can do this here and of course
you
don't have to use a Var, you
don't have to make it a
different line, you can assign
it right aso if expression, make
it nicer, and the result of the
expression is the all lasting in
the block.
So the same for When.  When is
not simply switch case on
steroid, it's largely
importantly an
expression, so you can also do
it like this, right.  So not
many returns here but one return
here will be a lot nicer.  Also,
you're going to story to repeat
yourself, of course, this much
and you
can say even this.
By the way, if you want to
check if something is odd and
even, don't do it like me.  It's
only for demo  purposes.  Don't
try this at home.  It will hurt.
(laughter).
Yeah, so this one can be
further
simplified like  this, so again
you're trying to remove the
noise.  When you see code like
this, just try to get rid of the
noise.  Noise is harmful for
your brain.
Last thing just a quick thing
with what you do with nullable.
These question marks are with
nullable types in Kotlin.  How
many people, I'll go really,
really quick, so you can have
nullable types and compiler
makes you do things like this,
and so it's an error now.  The
string is nullable you can't
reference it.
You can either do this, which
says just safely reference me,
which you by the way can do here
as well, right, so
you don't have to write an  "if"
around
it and can simplify it like
this.
Another nice thing is you can
use an alias operator like this,
so to simplify your like longer
if statements into something,
and this is kind of curious
because this is definitely the
expression position, right, so
how Elvis works.  Elvis takes an
expression on the left-hand side
of string and asks, are you a
null?
Really nicely, and if it's a
null it evaluates the right-hand
side.
But the right-hand side has to
be an expression, right.
Basically, it's supposed to be a
default, so like if you are null
on the left-hand side, like use
a default on
the right-hand side, but your
default can't be just a return,
which means you don't compute
any value there, you just jump
out of the function.
That's a quite an
interesting thing from the type
system standpoint but I'm not
giving a lecture here, I'm doing
a demo.
Okay.  We're good with
expressions.  Let's look at some
functional style.
So people very often refer to
Kotlin as a functional language.
I don't think it is, actually.
I think Kotlin is a
multiparadigm language that
supports functional style.  You
don't have to write functional
in Kotlin, but it's often times
very nice
to do it, so let's have a look
at this.
So in my Java old days in mind,
I
wrote this code which just goes
over a list of numbers and picks
those
devicable by 16 and converts
them to X.  So what it actually
does is filter map, right, map
is this one and filter is this
one.
So what I can do even with the
help of my ID, I can do this.
So newer versions of all
programming languages have
something like this.  I can
definitely leverage this, and so
this filter is a function, this
lambda is a function value.  You
don't have, by the way, to
declare it as a  variable.  You
can get rid of it.  And so
that's a lamb ka parameter.
Kotlin has some nice semi
functional things like you can
say anywhere in the code, it can
say also, and have this
value also do this for me,
please, like
print this list for me and then
proceed with what you were
doing, like nevermind this just
debug output or some side effect
I want to insert.  Side effects
are not functional on the one
hand, on the other hand this is
handy for debugging, you don't
have to break your clain apart
and so on and so  forth.  Also
use let, use run, and so on and
is forth.
There is one very deep thing
about functional abstractions in
non-functional languages.  When
I do something like this, I have
my repeat function right here,
right.  So what it does, it
takes a number of times I want
to repeat something and this
something is a function, and by
the way you don't have to invent
your own function interface
every time, just use the
function types here.  It's a
function that takes an INT
returns a unit, and unit is
something that you don't care
about.  Then it simply repeats
it, right.
So when I say repeat, I'm also
very
much conscious about like what's
it going to cost me?  Right?
So it's a function, it takes a
lambda as a parameter, and so
it's actually just another
parameter.  The Kotlin custom is
to write outside of parentheses
because it looks more like a
language construct like this,
but
then, okay, I'm running this and
I have to create a lambda
object, right.  I have to create
a lambda object every time I do
anything like this, and so there
is a cost to this abstraction.
It's nice code, I can reuse
things, I can raise the level of
abstraction in my code but there
is a toll on that.  Actually in
Kotlin, you can very often
get rid of the upgrading
lambdas, lambda objects for you
by just using inline functions.
When I say inline, my code
doesn't change, right.  So here
nothing happened at the call
site that I can see.
But if I say
show common byte code and just
decompile this into Java just to
scare
you a little bit, it was much --
yeah.  Easy talk so far.
So if I do this, here is goes.
It's a simple for loop.  Where
did my lambda go?
Well, the compiler simply
optimized it away.
You don't need lambda, right.
So if you simply have your loop
here
and you inline everything, you
end up with a loop and that's
it.
So the big difference in the
mindset when you go from the
Java Programming Language to the
Kotlin Programming  Language is
you still use lambdas but some
of the lambdas are really free,
and by the way these are all
free, too.
Many, many lambdas in the
library are free abstractions,
you don't have to pay for
calling them.  It's just code
generated for you.
So functional in Kotlin is
not only
convenient but also quite cheap.
Speaking of cheap, by the way,
let's look at this example.
So here I'm trying to do a
parallel computation.
Well, it's a stupid sample and
nobody does variable
computation, but I want to
illustrate a point.
What I'm doing here is again
with
my old habits in mind, I'm
creating 100,000 threads.
100,000 threads each of which
does some work.  Actually it
sleeps for one second and then
prints a number, and then I have
to join all of these threads to
my main thread.
So if I run this -- oh, oh.
There was an exception.  What
was that?
The Java out of memory error.
Basically, what it's telling me
is
hey, you cannot create 100,000
threads.  Are you crazy there?
It's 100,000 stacks, it doesn't
fit into memory, just get
reasonable.
And that's fair, like OS threads
are not cheap, you have to
allocate
resources for threads, so you
don't do such silly things with
thread, but I
have this example down
coroutines, who knows about them
in Kotlin?  Oh, good.  Who uses
them in production?  Okay.  Soon
enough you will all be using
them, I'm sure.  So have a look
here, it's very much
the same code so I'll just put
it side by side here.
It's very much the same code,
but instead of threads here I'm
creating async tasks that are
using co-routines underneath so
I'm still waiting for one
second and  printing, and if I
run this there is no out of
memory.  It's printing all the
numbers and I'm good.
So again, Kotlin introduced
coroutines as means of making
your
asynchronous computations nicer
and that  workers, but what's
the cost of that?  So the cost
of that is at least cheaper than
having a thread per each
computation, of course nobody
does that exactly, but still
like coroutines are very cheap.
You can spin off 100,000
coroutines and it doesn't costly
near as much as threads.
Let me illustrate something
that
coroutines are really good for
right here.
So here is a legacy interface.
Or I don't know, a motor
interface, I don't know.  What
we very often have to do to make
this asynchronous or reders very
denned
our dependencies so on and so
forth.  Ask me to do something
and I'll do it and let you know
when I'm done.  Here is the mock
service request and a callback
function that's passed to it so
when the work in the comments
are done, I'm calling the
callback and just passing my
answer there.
All right, so that's all right.
It's working for everyone,
right.  But this is what the
code looks like when I want to
exchange messages between two
services, and so I just want to
basically send two messages in
sequence, and here is what I
have to do.
First, request and then a
callback.  This is a result of
the request I printed, and then
next request inside
that callback and then print
inside, so
you see the stairways right here
staircase right here, right.
One step, two step, three step,
and you can actually get quite
deep down this staircase which
is not nice.
And so what I would really love
to do is something a lot more
straightforward, but so this is
kind of tolerable but what if,
just imagine,
what if you needed to do like N
calls?
Just a number of like make a
list of calls.  So this is the
code I came up with, which isn't
nice at all, so I definitely
need that there because I need
to nest a callback inside a
callback.  This is the shortest
code I came up with, it copies
arrays, don't do that.
It's  wasteful in terms of
memories and time, it's
quadratic.
Basically I have to come up
with something like this, so you
can't just say repeat this five
times, right.
So what I really want to do to
be able to do is something like
this where I just say, okay,
send one request, wait
for results, send the other
request, and
thenfy then if I want to repeat
something, just repeat it with a
for loop, right.
So this code here is
actually using the same
callbacks.
Only the coroutine abstractions
are pushing this away from me,
so actually
you can take any callback based
API that you have now and turn
it into this, like
make it straightforward with
just a few lines of code and
I'll show you.  So this is
calling the same services
because I have this function
right here.
So what I'm doing is I'm just
turning the request into a
suspension function through this
simple construct.  That's an
extension function of my
callback service.  I  say, the
first thing I say there is
suspend my coroutine, so I'm
assuming
I'm until a coroutine, suspect
spend it right away, I get the
continuation, I do my request,
that's it I'm suspended and
waiting for a request, and so
there it
is, and when the request is
done, I just say resume to my
coroutine and that's it.
So there simple lines of code
turns
your callback based API into a
coroutine API and makes -- so it
makes this -- oh, I'm sorry.
It makes this code into this,
which is a lot more readable to
my sense.  How do you like it?
(Applause).
I see some nods in the
audience.  Thank you.
Yeah, well, actually if you want
to be
a lot more prudent here and I'm
sure you want to, you need to
catch exceptions,
and so you know, capturing --
handling your exceptions is very
important and
that's as easy as this, just
catch your exception and
whatever happens on the -- oh,
I'm sorry.  Not here, of course.
Whatever happens with your
request,
just catch it and resume with
exception, so this will
propagate exceptions through
your coroutines very nicely and
you'll able to have try catch
around here, surround this with
try catch, or I'm sorry,
whatever, and catch exceptions
there as if it was a sequential
code but underneath it's all
asynchronous.
You can do HTTP requests like
this, async I/O file systems,
background
threads, everything you need.
Isn't it nice?
And I guess the last example
I'll be showing you today is
this one.
It's just another showoff for
how  coroutines can help you.
Take a look.
So what I wanted to do is to
create an infinite stream of
numbers.  Who likes infinite
streams of numbers?  I eat them
for breakfast.  Okay.
So I want just a sequence to be
generated here and then I can
take 20 of
them here, the sequence of 20
and I can
take 200, 2,000, filter, map,
slice, whatever.
And so this Build Sequence
function is a library function
and in the Kotlin standard
library and it's actually based
on the same mechanism as
coroutines.  It doesn't do any
background processing.  It's all
in the same thread.
What it does, it takes all the
yield statements from here and
just puts them in a sequence,
and so if I want to yield
something here, I just do it
like I
insert 2 into my sequence.
If I want to say say if TMP is
greater than 10, continue, I can
skip
pieces of my logic, so that's as
straightforward as any coroutine
it gives you a lazy sequence.
Okay.
So takeaways, classes are cheap,
functions are top level or
local, no
overloading to emulate your
default values, use properties,
use delegated properties, use
coroutines, have a nice Kotlin.
And I want to advertise some
more activities today.  So if
you still have questions that I
couldn't take, you can come over
to an
office hour we're having at
12:30.
You can come over to the sandbox
area C where we're at the Kotlin
booth some of the day at least,
and right after my
talk there will be a talk by
Jake Warden
about Android KDX, very exciting
on Stage 2, so you're welcome
there.  Thank you very much for
your attention.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.  Grand ambassadors
will assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who have registered for the next
session.  If you've registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask that you please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
May 10, 2018
10:30 a.m. PT
TensorFlow Lite for Mobile
Developers
morning, everyone.  Thank you so
much for coming to our session
this morning.  I'm Sarah
Sirajuddin.
I'll on the TensorFlow Lite
Team, and
we work on bringing Machine
Learning to mobile and small
devices.  Later on I will
introduce my colleague
Andrew Selle who will be doing
the second half of this talk.
So the last couple of days
have been really fun for me.
I've gotten to meet and speak
with
many of you, and it's been
really nice to see the
excitement around TensorFlow
Lite.
Today I'm happy to be here and
talk to you about all the work
that our team is doing to make
Machine Learning on small
devices possible and easy.
So in today's talk we'll cover
three areas.  First, we'll talk
about why Machine Learning
directly on device is important
and how it's different than what
you may do on the server.
Second, we'll walk you through
what we have built with
TensorFlow Lite.
And lastly, we'll show you how
you can
use TensorFlow Lite in your own
apps.
First, let's talk about devices
for a bit.
What do you mean when we say a
device?  Usually our mobile
devices are basically our
phones.  Our phones are with us
all the time, we interact with
them so many times during the
day.  And modern phones come
with a large
number of sensors on them which
give us really rich data about
the physical world around us.
Another category of devices is
what we call edge devices and
this industry has seen a huge
Explosion in the last few years,
so some examples are Smart
Speakers, Smart  Watches, Smart
Cameras, and as this market has
grown, we see the technology
which only used to be available
on more expensive devices is
now available on far cheaper
ones.
So now we see that there is this
massive growth in devices,
they're becoming increasingly
capable, both
mobile and edge, and there is
opening up
many opportunities for novel
applications for Machine
Learning.
I expect that many of you
are already familiar with the
basic idea of Machine Learning,
but for those that
aren't I'm going to quickly
cover the core concept.
Let's start with an example of
something we may want to do,
let's say classification of
images.  So how do we do this?
In the past what we would
have done
was to write a lot of rules that
were hard coded, very specific
about some characteristics that
we expected to see
in parts of the the im image.
This was time consuming, hard to
do, and frankly didn't work all
that well.  This is where
Machine Learning comes in.
With Machine Learning we
learn based on examples, and so
a simple way to think about
Machine Learning is that
we use algorithms to learn from
data and then we make
predictions about similar data
that has not been seen before.
It's a two-step process, first
the model learns and then we use
it to make predictions.
The process of model
learning is
what we typically call training
and when the model is making
predictions about data is what
we call inference.
This is a high-level view of
what's happening during
training.  The model is passed
in labeled data, that is input
data along with the associated
prediction.
And since in this case, we know
what the right answer is, we're
able to calculate the error,
that is how many times is the
model getting it wrong and by
how much?  We use these errors
to improve the model.  This
process is repeated many, many
times until we reach the point
that we think the model is good
enough or that this is the best
fit we can do.
This involves a lot of steps and
coordination and that is why we
need a
framework to make this easyier,
and this is where TensorFlow
comes in.  It's Google's
framework for Machine Learning,
it makes it easy to train and
build neural networks, and it is
cross-platform, works on CPUs,
GPU, TPUs, as well as mobile and
embedded platforms.
The mobile and embedded
piece of TensorFlow, which we
call TensorFlow Lite is what we
are going to be focusing on in
our talk today.
So now I want to talk about, why
would you consider doing Machine
Learning directly on device?
And there are several reasons
that you may consider, but
probably the most important one
is latency.  If the processing
is happening on the device, then
you're not sending data back and
forth to the server, so if your
use case involves  realtime
processing
of data such as audio or video,
then it's quite likely that you
would consider doing this.
Other reasons are that your
processing can happen even when
your
device is not connected to the
Internet, the data stays
on-device and this is really
useful if you're working with
sensitive user data which you
don't want
to put on servers, it's more
power efficient because your
device is not spending power
transmitting data back
and forth, and lastly, we are in
a position to take advantage of
all the
sensor data that's already
available and  accessible on the
device.
So this is all great but there
is a catch like there always is,
and the
catch is that doing on-device ML
is  hard.  Many of these devices
have some pretty
tight constraints, they have
small batteries, tight memory,
and very little computation
power.  TensorFlow was built for
processing on the server and it
wasn't a great fit for
these use cases, and that is the
reason that we built TensorFlow
Lite.  It's a lightweight
Machine Learning library for
mobile and embedded platforms.
So this is a high-level
overview of the system.  It
consists of a converter where we
convert models from TensorFlow
format to TensorFlow Lite
format, and for efficiency
reasons we use a format which
is different.  It consists an
interpreter which runs
on-device, there are library of
apps and kernel, and then we
have APIs that allow us to take
advantage of hardware
acceleration whenever it is
available.
TensorFlow Lite is
cross-platform
so it works on Android, iOS,
Linux, and a high-level
developer workflow here would be
to take a trained TensorFlow
model, convert it to TensorFlow
Lite format and then update your
apps to use the TensorFlow Lite
interpreter using the
appropriate API.
On iOS, developers also have the
option of using CoreML instead
and what
they would do here is to take
that trained TensorFlow model
and convert it
to CoreML using the TensorFlow
to CoreML converter and use the
converted model
with the
CoreML runtime.
The common questions we get
when we
talk to  developers is it small
and is it fast?  Let's talk
about the first question.  One
of the design goals with
TensorFlow Lite was to keep the
memory and binary size small,
and I'm happy to say that the
size of our core interpreter is
only 75 kilobytes and
when you include all the
supported ops, the size is 400
kilobytes.
How did we do this?
First of all, we've been really
careful about which dependencies
we include.
Secondly, TensorFlow Lite uses
flood
buffers which are far more
memory than protocol buffers
are.  Another thing is
selective registration and that
allows developers to only use
the ops that their model needs
and thus they can keep the
footprint small.
Now, moving on to the second
question which is of speed.  We
made several design choices
throughout the system to enable
fast startup, low latency, and
high throughput.
Let's start with the model
format.
TensorFlow Lite uses FlatBuffers
like I said and it's a
cross-platform efficiency
realization library.  It was
originally created at Google for
game development and is now
being
used for other performance
sensitive applications.
The advantage of using
FlatBuffers is very can
directly access the data without
doing parsing or unparsing of
the large files which contain
weights.  Another thing that we
do at the time
of conversion is that we pre
pre-fuse the activations and
biases and it leads to faster
execution later at runtime.
The TensorFlow Lite interpreter
uses a static memory and static
execution plan.
This leads to faster load times
times.  Many of the kernels that
TensorFlow Lite comes from have
been especially
optimized to run fast on NEON
and ARM CPUs.
Let's talk about hardware
acceleration.  As Machine
Learning has grown in
prominence, it has sparked quite
a bit of innovation at the
silicon layer as
well and many hardware companies
are investing in building custom
chips which can accelerate
neural income processing.
GPUs and DSPs which have been
around for some time are also
now being increasingly used to
do Machine Learning tasks.
TensorFlow Lite was designed to
take advantage of hardware
acceleration
whether it is through GPUs, DSPs
or custom AI chips.
On Android, the recently
released Android Neural  Network
API is an abstraction layer that
makes it easy for TensorFlow
Lite to take advantage of the
underlying acceleration.  And
the way this works is that
hardware renders write
specialized drivers or custom
acceleration code for their
hardware platforms and integrate
with the Android NN API.
It integrates with the Android
NN API via its internal
delegation API.
A point to note here is
that developers only need to
integrate their apps with
TensorFlow Lite.  TensorFlow
Lite will take care of
abstracting away the details of
hardware acceleration from them.
In addition to the Android NN
API we're also working on
building direct GPU acceleration
in TensorFlow Lite.
GPUs are widely available and
used and like I said before,
they're now being increasingly
used for doing Machine Learning
tasks.
Similar to NN API, developers
only integrate with TensorFlow
Lite if they want to take
advantage of the GPU
acceleration.
So the last bit on
performance that
I want to talk about is called
quantization and this cuts
across several components in our
system.
First of all, what is
quantization, a simple way to
think about it is that it refers
to techniques to store numbers
and to perform calculations of
numbers
in formats that are more compact
than 32-byte floating
representations.  Why is this
important?
For two reasons.
First, model size is a
concern for small devices, so
the smaller the model the better
it is.
Secondly, there are many
processers
which have specialized SIMD
which process faster than the
floating point numbers.
So the next question here
is how
much accuracy do we use if we're
using 8 bytes or 16 bytes
instead of the 32 bytes used for
representing floating point
numbers?  The answer obviously
depends on which model that
we're using, but in general
the learning process is robust
to noise and quantization can be
thought of as a
form of noise, so what we find
is that the accuracies tend to
be usually within
acceptable thresholds.
A simple way of doing
quantization
is to shrink the weights and
biases after training and we are
shortly going to be releasing a
tool which developers
can use to shrink the size of
their models.  In addition to
that, we have been actively
working on doing quantization at
training time and this is an
active area of ongoing research,
and what we find here is that we
are able to get accuracies which
are comparable to the floating
point models for architectures
like MobileNet as well as
Inception and we recently
released a tool which allows
developers to use this, and we
are working on adding support
for more models in this.
Okay.  So I talked about a bunch
of performance optimizations,
now let's talk about what does
it translate to in terms of
numbers.
So we benchmarked two models,
MobileNet and Inception V3 are
the pixel
tool and we're getting speedups
of more than three times.
When we compare
quantized quantized models and
these numbers do not include any
hardware acceleration.  We've
done some initial  benchmarking
with hardware acceleration and
we see
additional speedups of 3 to 4
times with that, which is really
promising and exciting so stay
tuned in the next few months to
hear more on that.
Now that I've talked about the
design of TensorFlow and
performance, I want to show you
what TensorFlow Lite can do in
practice.
Let's please roll the video.
So this is a demo demo
application which is running the
MobileNet classification model
which we trained on common
office objects, and as you can
see it's doing a good job
detecting them, even this
TensorFlow logo that we trained
this model on.
Like I said, it's
cross-platform so
it's running on iOS as well as
Android
and we also are running it here
on Android Pings.
This was a simple demo.  We have
more exciting demos for you
later on in the talk.  Now,
let's talk about production use
cases.  I'm happy to say that
we've been working with partner
teams inside Google
to bring TensorFlow Lite to
Google Apps,
so portrait mode on Android
camera, Hey
Google in Google Assistant and
SmartReply will be on TensorFlow
Lite in the next few months.
It's the version powering the
custom
functionality in the newly
announced ML Kit and for those
of you that may have
missed the announcement, ML Kit
is a
Machine Learning SDK, used Cloud
powered APIs for Machine
Learning and as well as
your ability to bring your own
custom models and use them.
These are some examples of apps
that are already using
TensorFlow Lite
via ML Kit, PicsArt a photo
editing and
collage making app, and VSCO is
a cool photography app.
So back to TensorFlow Lite and
what is currently supported, so
we have support for 50 commonly
used operations
which developers can use in
their own models.  I will point
out here that if you need an Op
which is not currently
supported, you do have the
option of using what we call a
custom Op and using that, and
later on in this talk, Andrew
will show you how you can do
that.
Op support is currently limited
to inference.  We will be
working on adding training
support in the future.
We support several common
popular Open
Source models as well as the
quantized counterparts for some
of them.
With this I'm going to
invite my colleague, Andrew, to
talk to you about how you can
use TensorFlow Lite in your
own apps.
>> ANDREW SELLE: Thanks,
Sarah.
(Applause).
So now that you know what
TensorFlow Lite is and what it
can do and where it can be run,
I'm sure you know -- you want to
know how to use it.  So we can
break that up into four
important steps.  The first one
and probably the most important
is get a model.  You need to
decide what you want to do.  It
could be image classification,
it could be object detection, or
it could be even speech
recognition.  Whatever that
model is, you need to train it
yourself and can you do that
with TensorFlow just like you
trained any other TensorFlow
model.  Or can you download a
pre-trained model if you're not
ready to make your own model
yet.
Or if an existing model
satisfies your needs.
Second, you need to convert your
model from TensorFlow to
TensorFlow Lite and we'll show
some examples of how to do that
in a second.
Third, if there is any
custom Ops that you need to
write, this could be because you
want to spot optimize something
with some special instructions
you know about, or it could be
that you're using a piece of
functionality that we do not yet
support like a
specialized piece of signal
processing.  Whatever it might
be, you can write your ops.
This may not be necessary, of
course.
The next step is to write
an app and you use whatever
client API is appropriate for
the target platform, so let's
dive into some code.  Converting
your TensorFlow model, once
you're done with the TensorFlow
training, you typically have a
saved
model or you might have a
graphdev, what you need to do
first is put this through the
converter so here I'm showing
how to do this within Python, so
if you download the normal
TensorFlow tooling that's
pre-compiled like the PIP,
you're
able to run the converter and it
just takes a save model
directory in or
frozen graphdev and you specify
a file
name of what TFLite file you
want and that inputs a
FlatBuffer on disk that you can
now shift to whatever device you
want.  How might you get it to
the device?  You could put it
into the package, or you could
also say distribute it through a
Cloud service where you can
update your model on the fly
without updating your core
application.
Whatever you want to do is
possible.
So next, once you've converted,
you might actually run into some
issues during the conversion
because there is a couple of
things that can go wrong.  So
the first one is you need to
make sure that you have a frozen
graphdev or save model.  Both of
these are able to get rid of the
parts of the graph that are used
for training, these are
typically things like variable
assignment, variable
initialization, optimization
passes.  These are not  strictly
necessary if you're doing
inference that is prediction, so
you want to get rid of those out
of the graph because we don't
want to support those operations
right now because we want to
have the smallest version of the
runtime that can be distributed
to keep your binary size small.
The second thing that you
need to do is make sure that you
write any custom operators that
you need, and now I'll go into a
little bit of an example of
doing that.  Well before that,
let me tell you one
more thing, which is we also
have some visualizers to let you
understand the model that you've
transformed and the
transformation process, so take
a look at those.  They're linked
off of the documentation.
So let's get into writing a
custom op?  What might we do?
Here I have an example that is
silly, but it's to return p.
The important thing when you
write an op is to perform C
functions so we have a C define
for writing operations and the
reason we do that is all of our
operations are implemented this
way so they can run on devices
that only
support C, eventually, you but
you can write kernels in C++.
In this case what I'm doing
is
ignoring the input tensors and
putting
in output tensor which is N pi.
If you have input tensors and
you want an output tensor you
could also read the input
tensors and say multiply by
three and now I have a multiply
by three operation.  This is
going to be application at the
pend dependent and as I said
before you don't always need to
do this.  I'm laying it out
because if there is some
functionality you need we are
extensible.
Okay, once you've converted your
model you need to use a client
API.  Let me start with the C++
API, but we have other language
bindings as well that I'll get
to.
But in any of the binding, it's
going to follow the same basic
pattern.
The pattern is create an
interpreter
and load the model, fill in your
data, execute the model and read
back the data.  Very simple.
In the C++ first thing you do is
create an object, this is given
the file name of the TensorFlow
Lite file and creates an object
that is going to hold that model
and M map it, so we use
FlatBuffers and the reason why
is because we can M map the
buffers which means there is
zero latency to start running
the model effectively.
Second, if you have any
custom operations, you can
register them, so basically at
this phase you're deciding
which operations to include into
your runtime.
By default we provide a built in
Op resolver that includes all of
our default operations.  You
might also use selective
registration that we alluded to
before where you include only a
subset of the operations, and in
this case you might provide a
minimal resolver and if you
wanted to use the custom
operation that we had before,
you would create a custom
resolver that would tell
TensorFlow Lite how to find your
custom operation.
So now we know what our Ops are
and where to get the code for
them, and we know our model.
Now we need to create an
interpreter object, so we take
the pair of model and resolver
and put it together and it
returns an interpreter.  This
interpreter is going to be our
handle for doing our execution,
so the next step is we're going
to perform an execution, but
before we can do that we need to
fill the buffer.  So if you have
a model like a classification
model, that is something that
takes an image in.  Where are
you going to get the image?  The
obvious place you might get it
is
maybe from your devices storage
if it's an image file name, or
also commonly it might be a
camera.  Whatever it might be,
you produce like
a buffer, and in this it's going
to be a float star and instar
buffer and you fill it into your
buffer.  Once you fill this
buffer, you're ready to run.  So
we filled our buffer, TensorFlow
Lite has all the information it
needs to
run the execution, and we just
call invoke.  Now it's going to
block until the execution is
done and then we're going to be
able to read the output of it in
an analogous way to our input
and so that is we can get a
float star buffer out which
could represent the class
numbers.  And then you're free
to do with that data whatever
you want, so for example in an
image classification app that we
showed before, you would read
that index out, map it back to a
string, and then
put it into your GUI display.
Great, so now we know how
to use C++.
What if you're using another
platform, for example,
RaspberryPi.
On RaspberryPi the most common
thing to use is probably
Python, and again it's going to
follow the same basic pattern.
First we create a interpreter
object, the interpreter object
is now our handle, how do we
feed data?
Since it's Python, we can use
num pi arrays and this is
convenient because if you need
pre-processing or post
processing you can do it with
primitives you're familiar with,
and this is kind of a theme that
goes on we want to keep
our bindings as idiomatic in the
language that they are and also
keep the performance, so in this
case we put in
some mun pi array and take out
some, so that's Python.
What if you're writing an
Android app or want to write an
Android Things application, then
you might use the Java API.  So
in this case, it's the same
thing.  You take and build an
interpreter, you give it the
file name of the interpreter, it
might be from a resource if
you're doing an Android
application, and then finally
you're going to fill the inputs
in and call run.
So one of the things that
we did for the Java API is that
we know that many Java
programmers don't really want to
deal with building their own
native library, so in that case
you can just use our Gradle file
here which will include our
precompiled version of
TensorFlow Lite.  You don't have
to download our source code, and
even for the tooling parts where
you do the conversion from
TensorFlow to TensorFlow Lite,
you can download the
pre-compiled version of
TensorFlow as I alluded to
before.
Great.  So whether a if
you're doing iOS?
This that case use the C++ API
and you can also use the
Objective C API, but
again we provide a precompiled
binary in
the form of a could he
.  Cocoapod.
I want to tell you what's
coming up in TensorFlow Lite.
One thing we're asked for is
more operation, the more
operations we have the more
models that can be run from
TensorFlow out of the box.  The
other thing that happens with
Machine Learning that is often
difficult is researchers come up
with new techniques all the
time, and that means that
TensorFlow is always adding
operations and that means that
we're going to continue to
follow TensorFlow as it adds
important operations and add
them into TensorFlow Lite as
well.
Okay.  The second thing we're
going to do is we're going to
improve the tooling, provide
better documentation, and
tutorials and try to focus on
ease of use, so it's really easy
for you to understand on
end-to-end examples how to
integrate TensorFlow Lite.
And the third thing, which
Sarah already mentioned but I'll
mention again, is that we're
excited about  on-device
training.  On-device training is
really exciting because it
allows us to refine a model
based on a user's experience.
It allows us to decouple that
experience from going to the
Cloud, so if they're
disconnected, we can continue
improving the model so there is
a lot of requests for this.
This will of course require more
and more computation on the
device, but
we're excited about upcoming
hardware accelerators that will
make this more and more
possible.
Okay.
One more question before we get
into some exciting demos.
When should I use TensorFlow
Lite?  As we alluded to before,
we're starting to use TensorFlow
Lite for
first-party applications and
third-party applications are
also using it.  That means that
what we're doing moving forward
is we're going to make
TensorFlow Lite our standard
solution for running ML on small
devices and mobile  devices.
TensorFlow Lite currently
supports a subset of TensorFlow
ops and this means that our
recommendation is that you
should use TensorFlow Lite if
you can
and let us know --
(overhead speaker -- let us know
of any missing functionality you
might need.  It's probably not
done.  With that I want to show
you a video of retrained models.
We showed you the
TensorFlow logo being
recognized, and this is a common
theme that we get which is that
people like our pre-trained
examples like MobileNet but they
may not have a application where
they need to tell the difference
between five dog breeds and many
zoo animals, they might have an
office area where they have
markers and whiteboards and as
we were testing the app we had
this issue too.  It's like we
don't have the classes that are
in these pre-trained models.
So one of the great things
one of our other TensorFlow
members created is something
called TensorFlow  For Poets and
there was a Codelab about that
and it's available online as
well, and it basically allows
you to take a pretrained image
model with really good detector
ability and put your own classes
into it.
I want to show you a demo app
that we created that runs on the
PC and creates TensorFlow Lite
models for you, so can we go to
the video?
Okay, so we showed you
before, can
we recognize scissors and
post-it notes?  Try it out.  You
always want to try the models.
The scissors look good.  Okay.
Great.  Post-it notes also looks
good.  What if we had another
object?
An object that is more common,
more
important, like this medal
TensorFlow logo?  Happens?
Everyday life, right?  Let's
take a look at how this does.
It's labeled as other, that's
not very good, but the great
thing about Machine Learning is
we can fix it.  The way we fix
it is to add data.  We have the
application and have gone to the
training tab.  Now we're going
to define a class called
TensorFlow, and this is
basically
short for TensorFlow logo and
now from
our website cam we're going to
click
capture a couple different
perspectives as many as we can,
and ideally on different
backgrounds so it doesn't
associate the background with it
being a TensorFlow logo and then
I click Train, and now it's
using TensorFlow to train the
model and it's converging to a
good validation accuracy, it's
going to reload the model, we're
testing in TensorFlow Lite
running on the PC right now and
we see it's  recognizing
TensorFlow correctly, so it's
that fast and easy, but also we
can take that
model and we can move to Android
and iOS and use the exact same
model and update it.  Thanks.
Now, let's move to a live
demo, so I'm going to go over
here to the podium.
(Applause).
All right.  So classification,
what I just showed you is kind
of this idea that you have an
image in and you put an image
out and you put classifications
out.  What if you have multiple
objects in the scene or
something in the corner of
an object?  You also want to
know where in the
scene that object is, and that
enters this model called
Singleshot detection, a type of
model and turns out our friends
in TensorFlow released a package
called object detection as part
of the TensorFlow models and it
allows us to use the pre-trained
model to recognize many classes.
What I've done is I want to
load it on a small  device.
We've shown you a lot of things
with small  devices.  I'm going
to show you another thing.  This
is a RaspberryPi.  It's another
cool example of a device because
it's cheap and easy to get so
any high school student can have
one of these, you can have many
of these and just use them for a
dedicated project, but the other
great thing about them is not
only are they relatively
powerful, but they're also able
to interface with
other hardware and have GPIO
pins and this can be capitalized
in a number of different ways,
but one way is to run Linux, and
that's what we're doing here.
But you can also use Android
Things
which you can see that the
sandbox has many examples doing
that, so can also do this with
Android Things.
In this case I have the system
board right here and it's
connected to a
motor controller, and this motor
controller is just a
microcontroller
that interfaces to server
motors, and the servers motors
can go left and right and up and
down and aim the camera.  Now
we're going to load the object
detection model on to this
device and we're actually going
to run it in order
to recognize different objects,
so let's go to the demo feed,
please.
We can see my app, you can
tell by the beautiful nature of
this app that I'm not a great
app developer, but this is what
I can do on a weekend, so give
me a little bit of slack.
Okay.  So here if we hold
up the apple, it's
rising the apple and it's
telling us what probability and
where the object is.  Now,
that's all good and fine but
when we couple it with the
ability to move, where I'm going
to turn on the motors now and
bring back the apple.
What I'm going to do is move the
apple in the screen and it's
going to try to keep it
centered, so as I move this
apple, it's basically going to
try to keep it centered, it's
like a little virtual camera
person, and this works on
other objects like this banana
here, hopefully.  Oh, there we
go, and it's going to keep that
centered.
If you put two objects in the
screen, it's going to try to
keep them both in.
Okay, so we have a little bit of
false detection, but it's
basically going to try to keep
them both centered.
So this is really a fun
application, and I bet you can
come up with many different
applications that are really
exciting to do with this type of
application, so can I go back to
the slides again?  I'll get my
clicker.
(Applause).
So like I said, this is
basically what I can do on a
weekend, but I imagine great app
developers and people with a
lot of creativity about
connecting devices and
connecting software can do many
interesting things.
So what I want to do now is I
want
to tell you in summary,
TensorFlow Lite, you've seen a
lot about it.  Basically, we
feel TensorFlow Lite makes
on-device ML  small, fast, and
easy, and we think that you're
going to find it very useful in
all of your applications and
we're excited to see what you
build.
Come talk to us.  I'm going to
be in office hours at 12:30.
You can come talk to me.  In
addition, you can come to our
sandbox if you haven't already,
and we have, of course the
examples that I
showed you here, we have the
tracking camera, we also have
the object classification on
mobile device, but
another cool thing that we have
is the donkey cars and this was
done by a group outside of
Google and we converted them
over to TensorFlow Lite and we
are
excited to see that their
application works really well
with TensorFlow Lite as well.
So with that, I hope you
check these things out.  I want
to tell you that if you want to
get started, you can go to our
documentation page, you can go
to the  TensorFlow.
org page and there is a TFLite
page that you can find more
information.  Our code is all
Open Source, get it on GitHub,
download it, modify it, submit a
pull request, and of course file
any issues that you have while
using it.
In addition, if you want to talk
about TensorFlow Lite, talk
about your applications, ask us
about feature
requests, please send to
our mailing list.
This community is exciting
exciting, in Open Sourcing
TensorFlow, people got really
exciting and we made it better
forever for people inside and
outside of Google and we hope
you'll engage TensorFlow Lite in
the same way TensorFlow has been
engaged.
With that I want to thank
you for
your attention, for coming to
I/O, for listening to our talk
about TensorFlow Lite, and I
also want to thank you -- thank
our Google partners.  This
product didn't come out of
isolation.  It came from all of
our experience building mobile
apps with machine intelligence,
and as we gained experience we
found that there was a common
need and that was the genesis of
TensorFlow Lite, so all of our
partners
provided provided application,
provided feedback, even provided
code and help with our model, so
thank you so much to you and to
them and enjoy the rest of I/O.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.  Grand ambassadors
will assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who have registered for the next
session.  If you've registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask that you please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
May 10, 2018
11:30 a.m. PT
Don't Let Your App Drain Your
User's Battery
-
lunchish, welcome everybody and
thank you for coming to talk
about battery.  It's another
year and I'm here again to talk
to you about power.
It's an ongoing project and as
you've probably saw from the
keynote, Dave
talked about Maslow's or his own
version
of the pyramid and I think
actually a lot is in this image.
Battery is foundational to
everything you're doing on your
phone, right.  If you don't have
power, you don't really have any
of the cool feature, you don't
have the camera, you don't have
the assistant.  Battery exists
to power all the other
things and it's a struggle for
us and a struggle for all of you
as well.  You want to do awesome
things for users and you also
want to save power so they can
do those things for longer, and
battery is actually a really
easy problem to solve if you
just kill everything, fixed,
I'll take my promotion, it's
great
The problem is it's
obviously much more nuanced than
that and that is a struggle that
we have internally every day
talking about power and what are
the right tradeoffs for users,
and that's always a really hard
question and we're going to talk
a little bit about that and some
of the things that we're
building into Android P to make
it a lot easier, and so the
first thing I want to
talk about is where is it going.
This is a horrifically
simplified, I'm sure some of the
engineering out there are like
oh, my God, he's showing this!
You have hardware, things like
how
much RAM you have on your device
cause a persistent drain on
what's happening there.
What hardware your OEM selected,
what you're using, how big your
screen is, how bright your
screen is all play into that
effect
You have the Os itself, is the
kernel being efficient, waking
up a lot, does it have a lot of
overhead?  Do you have disk
encryption, is it in software or
hardware?
Those things all effect your
overall power profile happening
under the hood
The next thing is absented
services and this is where we're
going to spend a bit of time
talking about today.  Obviously,
what apps you have on your phone
and services running that phone
drive power substantially,
largely through the CPU and
network activity
The last is the user's
interaction with the device
itself, how they behave, what
applications they use, how
quickly they respond to
notifications or don't, all
impacts the overall picture of
where
battery ends up.  A really
complicated topic, we're going
to talk largely about the bottom
left corner today, but the thing
I want to say before we get into
that is what other things have
we done and how does the things
we're going to talk about in P
affect the strategy?
We started in lollipop with job
scheduler and that was a
powerful tool to avoid apps
having to hang out on  services
all the time processing in the
background, but you could
schedule a piece of work and
have it done a finite
amount of time and the Os could
have variability on when to
schedule it.
next was doze and that was
targeted at you have the tablet
or phone, you put it down, not
using it, you put it in a drawer
and forget about it.  Hopefully
when you pull it out and use it
again a few days later it still
has a battery.  Doze was trying
to target that problem and was
largely successful
We had to go further, Doze on
the
go or Does light we call it
internally because it's faster.
That was targeted at phones.  I
have my phone in my pocket, I'm
not using it, but I'm moving
around and that's not in a
drawer.  That is like the in
exstep, is how do
we get that to be the next
scenario, and Doze was looking
at that.
You still don't want full Doze
but a little backed off and
We still needed to do more and
go deeper, the next is
background limits, largely
targeted at background services
as a whole, now we've had jobs
around for quite a while, and
also we're looking at background
limits for location and trying
to figure out what's the right
balance of applications looking
at location in the background
versus the foreground and ensure
there would be different
thresholds of what is
appropriate
Really good effect with
that, but
the only downside to what we did
with Oreo we needed apps to
target the Oreo  SDK, I'll talk
about that in a moment, in order
to support this.  P, since we're
here we're going to talk about
some more stuff that we're
working n the one thing I wanted
to take a moment because we're
mostly going to talk about
really cool ML and cool things.
There was a lot of brute force
optimization that the
engineering team
has also done and this was
looking at f2fs filesystem work
and how do we choose between
whether a process should be on a
small core or big core, and
looking at when to do CPU boosts
so you have buttery smooth
sliding but you're not just
purning power when the screen is
on in anticipation the user
might interact with the screen.
These are all things done over
the years.  This is a set we
just did on P, and there is
probably still more we're trying
to get done.
And then the thing is there
is still some of those big
challenges that are remaining
and this is what we're going to
talk about today.
What we noticed was battery
drain was roughly proportional
to the number of apps you have
on the phone, not the
number of apps you are using,
but how many you had installed.
And obviously that's not ideal,
and so we wanted to try to
remedy that.  We also saw a lot
of scenarios where apps are
accidently making mistakes,
like if you're working with
wakelock you're kind of playing
with fire and what happens when
the mistake happens?  Usually
the battery suffers.  Also some
developers are really aggressive
with the use case and trying to
be like oh, I must be there all
the time ready to go at a
moment's notice and sometimes
that might take a awful
lot of battery to achieve that
and is that really in the
interest of the  user, and how
can we help balance that back
out?
The last part is, even when
an app was aggressive or app had
a mistake, it wasn't obvious to
the user as to what to do.
They didn't know is the battery
menu going to help me, does it
tell me everything, does it
catch all the  cases, none of
the case, some of the cases?
Even when you saw a high battery
value, now what is this do I
uninstall, live with it, call up
the developer and send a
nastygram, that's something else
we wanted to look into
The next thing I mentioned
before
is the Oreo SDK, having apps
targeting the SDK to say I
understand how the background
limits work, I understand how
I can use Jobs and alarms
instead of using services.  As
you probably saw there was an
announcement late last year
talking about targeting
requirements for applications on
the Play Store, if you haven't
seen that Google that and find
out about it, you should be
looking at it because those
requirements are kicking in
later this year and that's going
to ensure then on P the majority
of apps on your phone are now
running the Oreo SDK and all of
these features we're talking
about  work.
So the high-level thing I want
to
talk about is a feature called
Adaptive Battery.  Battery Saver
and trying to make it better,
and additional restrictions
around background restrictions
to help users understand when
can I make it stop, can I have
another choice other than
uninstall, something in the
middle
between live with it and r
remove it
This pyramid is trying to
articulate, we want power
efficiency, we
like batteries that last a long
time, we want cool apps and we
don't want the use tore have to
manage between the things.  Cool
apps or power efficiency?  No
one wants to make that choice,
it's difficult, I don't want to
make it, no one wants to make
it, we want it just to work and
that's what this whole project
has been about, so with that I'm
going
to invite James up here to talk
about Adaptive Battery.  Thanks.
(Applause)
>> JAMES SMITH: Thank you very
much.  Hi, everyone.  Good
morning.  I'm James.
I'm rep sending the DeepMind
team today and we're pleased to
be here and working with Android
and excited about what we've
built together.
So as a user, you shouldn't
have to closely manage how your
apps behave on your device.
A modern intelligent operating
system should just take care of
it, and that's where Machine
Learning can help.
We've co-developed this feature
with Android called Adaptive
Battery.  It intelligently
aligns app power consumption
with app usage.
Apps can still run in the
background when they need to and
users
don't need to micromanage.
So Adaptive Battery uses the
concept of app App Standby
Buckets.  Every app is assigned
to the buckets.  Each bucket has
different limits on background
activity and there are four
buckets ranging from active to
rare.
Apps in the rare bucket have the
most restrictions and we use the
ML model to
assign apps to buckets based on
their predicted usage.
So for example, apps that are
predicted to be open in the next
few hours, I'm here at I/O, so I
might be using the I/O app and
so the I/O app is going to be in
the active bucket.  But in a few
days time when I'm back
at home,  Adaptive Battery is
going to automatically determine
that I'm unlikely to be using
this app and put it
into the rare bucket so it's not
unnecessarily consuming
resources like battery.
So what are the restrictions
that are applied?
Jobs,  Alarms, Firebase Cloud
Messaging, and Network are all
restricted in Android P
depending on which bucket the
app is in.
Apps in the active bucket have
no
restrictions, just like it is
today.  Working set has
restrictions on  jobs and
alarms, and frequent and rare
buckets introduce restrictions
on the
number of high priority Firebase
Cloud  Messages.  Messages
beyond that cap will be treated
as normal priority so that we
batch together with other
messages to save battery.
Generally, as developers you
should assume the background
activity will be deferred and
ensure that your app can work
under those conditions.  But one
thing to remember is once this
device is plugged into power,
all of the
restrictions are lifted.
There are ADB commands you can
use to test apps in each buckets
to make sure it performs as
expected.
Can you also use new framework
APIs to to get your apps current
bucket at runtime.
Most apps should be fine if
they're already following best
practices such as using Jobs for
background work and
targeting recent API levels like
Android Oreo.  As Ben just said,
this is going to be
a requirement for app updates on
the Splay Store later this year
so please make sure you target
the latest SDK  versions.
So let's talk a little bit about
Machine Learning.
The model was built by Android
in
DeepMind to predict which apps
go into which buckets.  We
should have done this with
simple heuristics or we could
have even just used past
behavior on the device but we
found that Machine Learning
allows us to capture the nuance
of how users behave with their
app, and I'll go into some
detail on how we built the model
in a second.
For those of you who are
interested in the architecture
of the model, we're
using a two-layer deep
convolutional
neural nets with a feet forward
neural net on top and this is
used to predict the probability
that an app will be opened in a
given interval.
You might have heard of
convolutional neural nets
before, particularly they're
common in image classifiers, but
we've used them to here to
measure higher levels --
higher-level
patterns of app usage over time.
Turns out they're pretty good at
that.
Now all of there is happening
on-device using TensorFlow, and
that's
actually a first for DeepMind.
We never deployed production
models on
the compute pair of a single
device, and a single mobile
device with the limited compute
power that's available is a
particular set of challenges,
and of course we're building
this Machine Learning model with
the intention of
attempting to save power, and if
we're
doing Machine Learning on-device
we have to be careful we're not
spending more power than we're
saving.
We're going to be making this
model
available to all device
manufacturers so they can take
it if they wish for their
devices on Android P or they can
implement their own or they can
take an Android Open Source
version of it as well.
So the model, we trained
the model
on millions of sequences of app
opens and transitions to
discover the patterns
of how users behave, so an
example would be if you use an
app at 8:00 in the morning every
morning, you're probably quite
likely to open it tomorrow at
8:00 as well.  But if you only
use a certain app on weekends
like a game or a travel app,
then you're probably not going
to open it on Monday morning,
and the model is
able to capture this nuance.
The model looks at the
user's behavior and outputs a
probability of when you're next
going to open a particular app.
The model compares the usage to
the patterns we've observed in
the data and
the behavior on-device will
influence the predictions given
by the model.
So we've also built this model
with certain principles in mind.
We tried to make it fair.
There is no favoritism of one
app over another.
If you use one particular app in
exactly the same way that I use
a different app, then the model
will output the same predictions
and they
will be assigned to the same
buckets.
It's sensitive, there is no
personal identifiable
information used by the model,
both when it's trained and when
it runs on the device.
The model only compares the app
usage on-device to our known
sequences of millions of app
transitions and it predicts when
you're next going to use that
app.
So if you combine the App
Standby Buckets and their
restrictions with this model
that predicts when you're next
going to open the app, that's
the Adaptive Battery feature.
It's a system that adapts the
phone to you.  The output of the
model is used to personalize the
Os' behavior to adapt it to how
you use the phone, so the apps
that you use get to run in the
background and the apps that you
don't,  don't.
We hope this will create a more
consistent battery experience
for users.
I'm now going to pass it over to
Madan a product manager on
Android to talk
about the  Battery Saver future.
Thanks very much.
(Applause).
>> MADAN ANKAPURA: Thank
you, James.
So let's talk about Battery
Saver.
Many of us run through the day
and as
we end the day we realize oh, I
won't be
actually able to make it.
Battery Saver is there to save
you.  Remember the red bars with
our animations that were janky
in Oreo?  Who liked those?
So we got rid of them.
We also actually turn off
Location and that helps battery.
In addition to that, many
device-specific features like
display for example are also
turned off.  All of these add up
in order to save
battery and prolong the device
battery so that you can go back
and charge the device.
We have also made some
changes in
the UI so that you can live on
this Moar for longer.  Now you
have a slider that you can
actually increase all the way to
the right, which probably allows
you to stay
on this mode if you choose to.
But what's also interesting is
what we
found is that if an app is being
used by
the user in this mode, having a
dark theme really helps.  Our
Internet tests show that apps
using dark theme save power
compared with the  ones that
don't.  So if you are a
developer that already supports
Dark Theme, please do think
about switching to  Dark Theme
when you
detect that the device is in
Battery  Saver.
There are a few commands that
you
can use
through ADB for force the device
into Battery Saver and test
them, and for
those of you that already
support that
mode, there are APIs like Power
Save Mode and broadcast that you
can use to
switch your device, or your app
theme to dark.
So let's jump into the battery
settings itself.
We think when the user actually
goes into a battery setting,
probably they are having a bad
battery day.
You want to make the user very
easy to take actions.
You want to keep the UI
simplified,
and we will tell you exactly
what applications might be
causing the battery drain, so it
will be much more opinionated
about these things.
In addition to that as you
scroll down, we'll also be able
to see how long
your battery will last, and that
number
is also powered by an ML
monitor.
So let's jump into that
opinionated background
restrictions.  So we have some
principles upon which we have
built this particular feature.
User asks for  controls, they
want to know like which app is
doing what so that this he can
take a quick action on them.
We also want to make sure that
apps that don't necessarily
target Oreo are
also being well managed by the
user, and
lastly our goal is to make sure
that apps don't get restricted
in the first place, so that way
apps fundamentally are a better
battery citizen.
So with P, we will actually
launch
this future with two specific
criteria.
The first one is if your app is
still not targeting Oreo and has
a background
service, the second one is if an
app
holds wakelocks or what call
stuck wakelocks for more than an
hour in the background, both of
these are very well
understood causes for battery
drain.
There are more such reasons.
We today present those reasons
within
Play Developer Console and we
call them Android Vitals so we
are in the future
going to be looking at many such
signals in order to incorporate
coming up with new rules for
background restrictions.
So what does it mean for your
app in case if the user decides
to restrict them?
As James talked about jobs,
alarms, services, and network,
the apps will not
be able to do any of those in
the background.  There are some
explicit intents, for example,
location will not be delivered
to those applications, so we're
trying
to minimize the reasons why an
app
should be able to use device
resources when it is in the
background.
And lastly, if an app is in
the background and restricted,
it won't be
able to use foregone services.
So as I spoke earlier, I
hope many
of you are already familiar with
Android Vitals, and if not I
would strongly recommend to you
go take a look into
what signals do we actually show
in their there and how your app
is behaving.
We have heard many success
stories of application
developers using this
data in order to improve their
applications, and we in fact use
some of
these signals internally also to
make Os better.  Trying to
figure out like what kind of
changes we could be making in
order to
have the right guardrails within
Os to
make sure that apps don't
accidently drain battery.
There was a session about it, if
you haven't had a chance to
listen to those, please take a
look at the  recording.
So we made the UI simplified,
but
there might be several of you
who would fall into as power
users, so you do like graphs and
you do like number of
percentages, so we do have it in
the overflow menu.
Now the graph is improved with
better predictions and the user
can take action from this screen
if you
see any app that is not
necessarily surprising you as
being consuming more battery.
So from here you can directly
preemptively restrict
applications or unrestrict them.
This is a good user control for
users to have.
So how do you test for
this?
Again,
there is ADB to put them in the
state and test them while
they're in the state.  Note that
even an app who has been
restricted could still be used
by the
user by launching them
explicitly so you want to make
sure that they still work.
So we have gone through
some of the
key features in  P, and what
does it mean for you as an app
developer to continue to
actually deliver your
features using various
things that are offered like
Jobs, and so on and so forth,
what does it mean for you to do
a background work?
You might have actually seen
this flowchart before.  Ben
presented it last year.  It
literally went through what is
it that you want to do and
offered some choices.  We want
to simplify our recommendation,
and thanks to Jetpack,
in it we have a great tool.
So it will simplify it now
hopefully.  If you want to think
about doing anything in the
background, we highly recommend
you to actually evaluate Work
Manager as a go-to thing.  And
if you think it's something that
is really important and must
happen now, of course you have
the ability to use foreground
services.  But note that if you
use foreground services, you
have to tell the user why you
are using it for because there
will be a notification and
you'll have to justify yourself
as to why you think it is
important.
And now because of that, if
you
change your mind, go back to
WorkManager.
So if none of this worked, think
about actually doing the work
when the app actually is
launched and being  actively
used by the user, so the
choices are hopefully very
simplified.  All of this really
helps us manage battery better
and that will lead to
having a better battery life.
There have been some
sessions that have already
happened so I want to call
and shout out to Jetpack which
talks
about WorkManager and there was
also a
session on Android Vitals and
there is a video.  There is a
detailed documentation of the
features that we talked about.
Please head over to d.android.
com/power, and finally since we
won't be
taking any questions, please do
find us.
All three of us will be in the
office hours from 2:30 to 3:30
in the office
hour space, so look for Android
Framework office hours.
And finally, if you have any
feedback here is our URL and
thank you.
(Applause).
>> Thank you for joining
this session.  Grand ambassadors
will assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We'll be making room for those
who have registered for the next
session.  If you've registered
for the next session in this
room, we ask that you please
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
Advances in Machine Learning and
TensorFlow
Breakthroughs in Machine
Learning
>> At this time, please find
your seat. Our session will
begin soon.
>> Hi, everybody, and welcome
to this session, where we're
going to talk about
breakthroughs in machine
learning. I'm Laurence Moroney,
a developer advocate working on
TensorFlow. We're here today to
talk about the revolution that's
going on in machine learning and
how that revolution is
transformative. Now, I come from
a software development
background. Any software
developers here?
Given that it's I/O, sure. This
transformation is particularly
from a developer's perspective,
is really, really cool, because
it's giving us a whole new set
of tools that we can use to
build scenarios and to build
solutions for problems that may
have been too complex to even
consider prior to this.
It's leading to massive advances
in our understanding of things
like the universe around us.
It's opening up new fields in
art. And it's impacting and
revolutionizing things like
healthcare and so many more
things. Should we take a look at
some of these? First of all,
astronomy.
At school I studied physics. I'm
a physics and astronomy geek.
It wasn't that long ago when we
learned about new planets.
The way we discovered it is,
sometimes we would observe a
wobble in the star.
That meant there was a large
planet orbiting the star closely
and causing a wobble because of
the gravitational attraction.
The kinds of kind of planets
we want to find are like Earth,
where there's a chance of
finding life. And finding those
and discovering those was very,
very difficult to do because
small ones, close to a star, you
wouldn't see.
But, with research that's been
going
on, they've recently discovered
Kepler
90I by sifting through data and
building models for using
machine learning and TensorFlow.
And Kepler 90I is much closer to
its home star than Earth.
The orbit is 14 days instead of
365.
And not only that, which I find
really cool, they didn't just
find this as a single planet
around that star. They've mapped
and modeled the entire solar
system of eight planets that are
there. So these are some of the
advances. To me, I find this a
wonderful time to
be alive, because technology's
enabling us to discover these
great new things. Even closer to
home, we've also  discovered
that looking at scans of the
human eye, as you would have
seen in the keynote, with
machine learning trained models
on this, we've been able to
discover things such as blood
pressure predictions, or being
able to assess a person's risk
of a heart attack or a stroke.
Now, just imagine if this
screening can be done on a small
mobile phone.
How profound is the effect going
to be? The world will be able to
access easy,
rapid, affordable, and
noninvasive screening for things
such as heart diseases. It will
be saving many lives and
improving the quality of many,
many more lives. Now, these are
just a few of the breakthroughs
and advances that have been made
because of TensorFlow. And
TensorFlow, we've been working
hard with the community with all
of you to make this a machine
learning platform for everybody.
So today we want to share a few
of the new advances that have
been working
on this, including we'll be
looking at robots. And Vincent
will come out to show us robots
that learn and some of the work
that they've been doing to
improve how robots learn.
And then Debbie is going to be,
from NERSC, showing us cosmology
advancements, including how
building a simulation of the
universe will help us understand
the nature of the unknowns in
our universe like dark matter.
First of all, I would love to
welcome
from the Magenta team, Doug, a
principal scientist. Doug.
>> DOUGLAS ECK: Thanks,
Lawrence.
(Applause)
>> DOUGLAS ECK: Thank you
very much. All right. Day three.
We're getting there.
Hi, everybody, I'm Doug, a
scientist at Google working on a
project called Magenta. Before
we talk about modeling the
entire known universe, before we
talk about robots, I want to
talk about music and art, and
how to use machine learning for
expressive purposes. So, I want
to talk first about a
drawing project called sketch
RNN, where we trained a neural
network to do something as
important as draw the pig that
you see on the right there.
And I want to use this as an
example
to highlight a few important
machine learning concepts that
we're finding to be crucial for
using machine learning in the
context of art and music.
So, let's dive in. It's going to
get a little technical,
hopefully it will be fun. We're
going to try to learn to draw
not by generating pixels, but
pen strokes. This is a very
interesting representation to
use because it's close do what
we do when we draw. Specifically
we're going to take the
data from the popular quick draw
game,.
That was captured as delta X
movements of the pen.
We know when the pen is put down
and lifted up. That's our
training domain.
One thing I would observe is we
didn't need a lot of this data.
It fits the creative process.
It's closer to drawing, I argue,
than pixels are.
It's modeling the movement of
the pen.
Now, what we're going to do with
these
drawings is push them through an
auto-encoder. On the left, the
encoder network's job is to take
the strokes and encode them in
some way so that they can be
stored
as a latent vector. The job of
the decoder is to decode that
into a generated sketch.
And the only point that you
really need to take away from
this talk is that that latent
factor is worth everything to
us.
First, it's smaller in size than
the encoded or decoded drawing.
It can't memorize everything.
Because of that, we get nice
effects. For example, you might
notice if you look carefully
that the cat on the left, and
which is actual data and has
been pushed through the trained
model and decoded, is not the
same as the cat on the right,
right?
The cat on the left has five
whiskers. The model regenerated
the sketch with six because
that's what it usually sees. Six
is general. It's normal to the
model, whereas five is hard for
the model to make sense of.
So this idea of having a tight,
low-dimensional representation,
the latent vector that's been
trained on lots of data, the
goal is the model might learn to
find generalities in a drawing,
learn general strategies.
So here's an example of
starting each of the four
corners with a drawing done by a
human, David, the first author.
And those are encoded in the
corners. Now we move linearly
around the space -- not the
space of the strokes, but the
space of the latent vector. If
you look closely, I think you'll
see that the movements and the
changes from these faces say
from left to right, are actually
quite smooth. The model has
dreamt up all of those faces in
the middle. To my eye they
really do fill the space of
possible drawings.
Finally, as I pointed out
with the cat whiskers, the
models generalize, not memorize.
It's not interesting to memorize
a drawing. It's more interesting
to learn general strategies for
drawing. We see with the cat.
I think more interestingly --
it's also suggestive -- we see
this with doing something like
taking a model that's only seen
pigs and giving it a picture of
a truck. What's that model going
to do? It's going to find a pig
truck, because that's all it
knows about. And if that seems
silly, which I grant it is, in
your own mind think about how
hard it would be, for me, if
someone says draw a truck that
looks like a pig.
It's hard to make that
transformation.
And these models do it.
Finally, by the way, I get paid
to do this. I just want to point
that out as an aside. It's kind
of nice. I said that last year.
It's still true. These latent
space analogies, another
example. If you add and subtract
pen strokes, you're not going to
get far with making something
that's recognizable. But if you
have a look at these analogies,
we take the latent vector for a
cat head and we add a pig body.
And we subtract the pig head.
And of course it stands to
reason that you should get a cat
body. We can do the same thing
in reverse. This is real data.
This works. I mention it because
it shows that these models are
learning some of the geometric
relations between the forms that
people draw.
I'm going to switch gears and
move from
drawing to music, talk about a
model
called  Nsynth, that generalizes
audio. You may have seen from
the beginning of I/O with
bathing that this has been put
into a  hardware unit. How many
people have heard of super?
How many people want an ensign
super? Good. That's possible, as
you know.
For those of you that didn't
see the opening, I have a short
version of the
making of the NSynth to give you
an idea of what the model is up
to.
Let's roll it.
>> Here's a flute.
Here's a snare. I guess in the
middle, this is what it sounds
like.
>> It does feel like what
could be a new possibility.
It could generate a sound that
might inspire.
>> The fun part is even though
you think you know what you're
doing, there's some weird
interaction happening that can
give you something totally
unexpected.
>> Wait, why did that happen
that way?
>> DOUGLAS ECK: Okay.
So, what you see here -- by the
way, the last person was Jesse,
the main
scientist on the NSynth project.
This grid that you're seeing,
this square where you can move
around the space, is exactly the
same idea as we saw with those
faces. You're moving around the
latent space,
able to discover sounds that
have some similarity. Because
they're made up of learning what
makes humans -- how sound works
for us in the same way as a pig
truck gives
us new ideas about how sound
works.
As you probably know, you can
make
these yourself, which my
favorite part about it.
This is open source, GitHub.
For those of you who like to
tinker, give it a shot. If not
we'll see some coming from tons
of people who are building them
on their own.
So, I want to keep going with
music. I want to move away from
audio to musical scores, musical
notes, something
that think of last night driving
the sequencer.
And talk about basically the
same idea. Can we learn a latent
space where we
can move around what's possible
in a musical score?
So what you see here is some
three-part musical thing on the
top, and some one-part musical
thing on the bottom, and then
finding in a latent space
something that's in between,
okay?
And now, I put the faces
underneath this. What you're
looking at now is a
representation of a musical drum
score
where time is passing left to
right. I'm going to play this
for you. It's a little bit long.
We're going to start with a drum
beat, one measure of drums, and
we're going to end with one
measure of drums. You're going
to hear those first, A and B.
Then you're going to hear this
latent space model try to figure
out how to get from A to B. And
everything in between is made up
by the model in exactly the same
way that the faces in the middle
are made up by the model.
So as you're listening,
basically listen for whether it
makes musical sense or not, the
intermediate drums. Let's give
it a roll.
>> DOUGLAS ECK: There you
have it.
(Applause)
>> DOUGLAS ECK: Moving right
along, take a look at this
command.
This may make sense to some of
you. We were surprised to learn
that this is not the right way
to work with musicians and
artists. I laughed, too. We
thought this is a great idea,
guys. Paste this into Terminal.
They're like what's terminal?
You know you're in trouble.
We've moved quite a bit towards
trying to build tools that
musicians can use. This is a
drum machine that you can
play with online built around
TensorFlow.JS. I have a short
clip of this being used.
You're going to see all the
red is from you. You can play
around with it. The blue is
generated by the model. Let's
give this a roll.
This one is quite a bit shorter.
>> DOUGLAS ECK: So this is
available
for you as a code pen which
allows you to play around with
it, and really
amazing, a huge shoutout to Tero
who did this. He grabbed one of
our  training models
and used TensorFlow and hacked
code and put it on Twitter. We
had no idea this was happening.
And then we reached out to him
on Twitter. I said you're my
hero. He said you care about
this? I'm like, of course,, this
is our dream, to have people
playing with this technology. I
love that we've gotten there.
Part of what I want to talk
about today -- actually close
with, we've cleaned up a lot of
the code. Tero helped. We're
able to introduce Magenta.JS,
very tightly integrated with
TensorFlow, and it allows you to
grab a
checkpointed model and set up a
player, and start sampling. In
three lines of code you can set
up a drum machine.
We have the art side as well.
And we've seen a lot of demos
driven by this, a lot of
interesting work by  Googlers
and people from the outside.
And I think it highly aligns
with what we're doing. We're
working to engage with musicians
and artists, very happy to see
the JavaScript stuff come along,
which seems to be the language
for that. Hoping to see better
tools come, and heavy engagement
with the open source community.
If you want to learn more,
please visit the website. Also,
you can follow my Twitter
account. I post regular updates
and try to be a connector for
that. So  that's what I have for
you. Now I'd like to switch
gears and go to
robots, with my colleague,
Vincent Vanhoucke. Thank you
very much.
(Applause)
>> VINCENT VANHOUCKE: Thanks,
Doug.
So, my name is Vincent and I
lead the Brain robotics research
team, the
robotics research team at
Google.
When you think about robots, you
may think about precision and
control.
You may think about robots, you
know, that live in factories.
They've got one very specific
job to do and they've got to do
it over and over again.
But as you saw in the keynote
earlier,
more and more robots are about
people. Right? They're
self-driving cars that are
driving in our streets,
interacting with people.
They essentially now live in
our world, not their world.
And so they really have to adapt
and perceive the world around
them, and
learn how to operate in this
human-centric environment. How
do we get robots to learn
instead of having to program
them? This is what we've been
embarking on.
And it turns out we can get
robots to learn. It takes a lot
of robots.
It takes a lot of time.
But we can actually improve on
this if we teach robots how to
behave collaboratively.
So this is an example of a
team of robots that are learning
together how to
do a very simple task like
grasping objects, right?
At the beginning, they have no
idea what they're doing. They
try, and try, and try. And
sometimes they will grasp
something. Every time they grasp
something, we give them a
reward. And over time, they get
better and better at it. Of
course, we use deep learning for
this.
We basically have a network that
maps those images that the
robots see of the  workspace in
front of them to actions and
possible actions.
And this collective learning
of
robots enables us to get to
levels of performance that we
haven't seen before. But it
takes a lot of robots. And in
fact, you know, this is Google.
We would much rather use lots of
computers if we could instead of
lots of robots. And so the
question becomes, could we
actually use a lot of simulated
robots,
virtual robots, to do this kind
of task and teach those robots
to perform tasks?
And would it actually matter
in the real world? Would what
they learn in simulation
actually apply to real tasks?
And it turns out the key to
making this
work is to learn simulations
that are more and more faithful
to reality.
So on the right here you see
what a typical simulation of a
robot would look like.
This is a virtual robot trying
to grasp objects in simulation.
What you see on the other side
here may look like a real robot
doing the same task, but in
fact, it is completely simulated
as well.
We've learned a machine learning
model that maps those simulated
images
to real images, to real-looking
images that are essentially
indistinguishable from what a
real robot would see in the real
world. And using this kind of
data and
training a simulated model to
accomplish tasks using those
images, we can transfer that
information and make it work in
the real world as well.
So there's lots of things we can
do with these kinds of simulated
robots.
This is Rainbow Dash, our
favorite little pony. And what
you see here is him taking his
very first steps.
Or very first hops, I should
say. He's really good for
somebody who's just starting to
learn how to walk. And the way
we accomplished this is by
having a virtual Rainbow Dash
running in simulation.
We train it using deep
reinforcement learning to run
around in the simulator. And
then we can basically download
the model that we've run in the
simulation onto the real robot
and actually make it
work in the real world as well.
There are many ways we can
scale up robotics and robotic
learning in this way. One of the
key ingredients turns out to
be learning by itself,
self-supervision, self-learning.
This is an example, for example,
what you see at the top here is
somebody driving a car.
And what we're trying to learn
in this instance is the 3D
structure of the world, the
geometry of everything.
What you see at the bottom here
is a representation of how far
things are from the car. You
probably are looking at avoiding
obstacles and looking at other
cars to not collide with them.
And so you want to learn
about the 3D geometry based on
those videos.
The traditional way that you
would do this is by  involving,
for example, a 3D camera, or
something that gives you a sense
of depth. Here we're going to do
none of that.
We're going to simply look at
the video and learn directly
from the video the 3D structure
of the world.
And the way to do this is to
look at the video and try to
predict the future of this
video. You can imagine that if
you actually understand the 3D
geometry of the world, you can
do a pretty good job at
predicting what's going to
happen next in the video.
So we're going to use that
signal that tells us how well
we're doing at predicting the
future to learn what the 3D
geometry of the world looks
like. So at the end of the day,
what we end
up with is yet another big
convolutional network that maps
what you see at the top to what
you see at the bottom without
involving any 3D camera or
anything like that.
This idea of self-learning or
just learning without any
supervision directly from the
data is really, really powerful.
Another problem that we have
when we're trying to teach
robots how to do things is that
we have to communicate to
them what we want, what we care
about, right? And the best way
you can do that is by simply
showing them what you want them
to perform.
So here is an example of one of
my colleagues basically doing
the robot dance.
And the robot that is just
looking at him performing those
tasks, and trying to imitate
visually what he is doing. And
what's remarkable here is that,
you know, even though the robot,
for example, doesn't have legs,
it tries to
do this crouching motion as best
it can
given the degrees of freedom
that it has available.
And all of this is entirely
self-supervised.
The way we go about this is that
if you
think about imitating somebody
else, for example, somebody
pouring a glass of
water, or a can of Coke, it all
relies
on you being able to look at
them from a third-party view and
picturing yourself
doing the same thing from your
point of view, what it would
look like if you did the same
thing yourself, right? So we
collected some of this data that
looks like that where you have
somebody looking at somebody
else do a task and
you end up with those two videos
of one taken by the person doing
the task and another one taken
by another  person.
And what we want to teach the
robots is that those two things
are actually the same thing.
So we're going to use, again,
machine learning to perform this
matchup. We're going to have a
machine learning model that is
going to tell us, okay, this
image on the left is actually of
the same task as this image on
the right. And once we've
learned that correspondence,
there lots of things we can do
with this. One of them is just
imitation like this. Imagine you
have somebody pouring a
glass of water, the robot sees
them,
they try to picture themselves
doing the same task, and try
best they can to imitate what
they are doing.
And so using, again, deep
reinforcement learning, we can
train
robots to learn those kinds of
activities completely based on
visual observation without any
programming of any kind.
So I won't let that robot pour
quite yet, but it's encouraging
that we can look at robots that
understand essentially what the
nature, what the fundamentals of
the task is regardless of
whether they're pouring a
liquid, or
they're pouring beads, or
whatever the glasses look like
or the containers. All of that
is  abstracted and the robot
understands deeply what the task
is about.
So I'm very excited about this
whole
perspective on teaching robots
how to learn instead of having
to program them, right.
At some point I would want to be
able to tell my Google assistant
hey, okay, please go fold my
laundry, right.
And for that to happen, we're
going to have to rebuild the
science of robotics from the
ground up.
We're going to have to base it
on  understanding and machine
learning, and perception, and of
course we're going to
have to do that at Google scale.
With that, I'm going to give
the stage to Debbie, who is
going to talk to us about
cosmology. Thank you.
(Applause)
>> DEBORAH BARD: Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Debbie Bard, and I'm
going to be talking about
something a little bit
different. So I lead the data
science engagement group at
NERSC. And NERSC is the National
Energy Research Scientific
Computing Center.
We're a supercomputing center at
Lawrence Berkeley National Lab
just over the bay from here. We
are the mission computing center
for the Department of Energy
Office of Science. We have
something like 7,000 scientists
using our supercomputers to work
on some of the biggest questions
in science today.
And what I think is really cool
as well is that I get to work
with some of
the most powerful computers on
the planet. One of the things
we're noticing is we've seen
that scientists are increasingly
turning to deep learning and
machine learning methods to
solve big questions that they're
working on. We're seeing these
questions showing up in our
workload on our supercomputers.
So I want to focus on one
particular topic area. It's very
close to my heart, which is
cosmology, because I'm a
cost moll
cosmologist by training.
I've always been interested
in the nature of the universe.
Perhaps one of the most basic
questions
you can ask is, what is it made
of?
These days, we have a fairly
good feel for how much dark
energy there is in the universe,
how much dark matter, how much
regular matter there is in the
universe. And there's only about
5% of regular matter, which is
everything that you and
I, and all the stars, dust, gas,
and galaxies out there are made
of regular matter. That makes up
a pretty tiny proportion of the
content of the universe.
The thing that I find really
interesting is we just don't
know what the rest of it is.
Dark matter, we don't know what
that's made of.
But we see indirectly the
gravitational effect it has.
Dark energy, we don't know what
that is. It was recently
discovered. Dark energy is a
name we give to an observation
which is the accelerated
expansion of the universe. And
this is, I think, really
exciting. The fact that there is
so much that we have yet to
discover means that there are
tremendous possibilities for new
ways for us to understand our
universe.
And we are building a bigger and
better telescope. We're
collecting data all the time,
taking images and observations
of the sky to get more data to
help us
understand this, because we only
have one universe to observe. We
need to collect as much data as
we can and extract all the
information we
can from our data, from our
observations. And cosmologists
are turning to deep learning to
extract meaning from our data.
I'm going to talk about a couple
of different ways we're doing
that. First of all, I want to
ground this in
the background of how we
actually do experiments in
cosmology, because cosmology is
not an  experimental science in
the way that many of the
physical  sciences are.
There's not a lot we can do to
experiment with the universe. We
can't really do much to change
the nature of space time,
although it would be fun if we
could. Instead we have to run
simulations. We run simulations
in super computers
off theoretical universes and to
different physical models and
the different parameters that
control those physical models.
And that's how we experiment. We
run the simulated universes and
compare the outputs of the
simulations to our observations
of the real universe around us.
So when we make this
comparison, we're typically
using some statistical measure,
some kind of reduced statistic
like the power spectrum, which
is illustrated in this animation
here.
The power spectrum is a measure
of how matter is distributed
throughout the universe, whether
it's, kind of, distributed
fairly evenly throughout space
or whether it's clustered on
small scales.
And this is illustrated in the
images on the top of the slide,
snapshots of a
simulated universe run in the
super computer.
And you can see that over time,
gravity is pulling matter
together. And so that's dark
matter and regular matter.
Gravity is acting upon that,
collapsing
the matter into very typical
cluster type structures, whereas
dark energy is expanding space
itself, expanding the volume of
this miniature universe.
And so by looking at the
distribution of matter, we can
start to learn something about
the nature of the matter
itself, how gravity is acting on
that, and what dark energy is
doing.
But as you can imagine,
running these
kinds of simulations is very
computationally expensive, even
if
you're only simulating a tiny
universe, it still requires a
tremendous amount of compute
power. And we spend billions of
compute hours on supercomputers
around the world on
these kinds of simulations,
including the supercomputers
that I work with.
And one of the ways that we're
using
deep learning is to reduce the
need for such expensive
simulations, similar to the
previous speaker was talking
about in robotics.
We're exploring using
generative
networks to produce, in this
case, this
example, two-dimensional maps of
the universe. These are maps of
the mass concentration of the
universe. You can imagine the
three dimensional volume
collapsed into a
two-dimensional projection of
the mass density in the universe
as you're looking out at the
sky.
And we use a fairly standard DC
topology to produce new maps
based on simulations.
So this is an augmentation.
We're using this network to
augment an existing simulation.
And we see that it's doing a
pretty good job. So just by
looking by eye at the generated
images, they look pretty similar
to the real simulated images. As
a scientist, squinting at
something and saying that looks
about right is not good enough.
What I want is to be able to
quantify
this, how the network is working
and how like the real images our
generated images are.
And this is where scientific
data has a real advantage
compared to natural
image data, because scientific
data usually, very often, has
associated statistics with it.
So statistics that you can use
to evaluate the success of your
model. So in this case, we were
looking at reduced statistics
that describe the
patterns in the maps, like the
power spectra and other measures
of the topology of the maps. We
see that not only do the maps
look about right, but the
statistics that are contained in
those maps match those from the
real simulations.
So we can quantify the accuracy
of our network. And this is
something that potentially could
be useful for the wider deep
learning community, using
scientific data that has
statistics could be of real
interest to deep learning
practitioners in trying to
quantify how well your networks
are working. So I mentioned
before that this is an
augmentation that we've been
working on so far. It can
produce new maps based on a
physics model that it's already
seen. We're working at producing
physics models that the network
has never seen, making this into
a true emulator.
This will help reduce the
need for
these expensive simulations and
allow cosmologists to explore
space more freely. I'd like to
explore a little bit further
what this network is actually
learning. I saw an interesting
talk this morning
here touching on this kind of
thing, how we can use machine
learning to gain insight into
the nature of the data that
we're working with. So in the
work that I'm showing here, we
were looking at which structures
in our mass maps are
contributing to the model, most
strongly contributing, by
looking at a quantity called
saliency.
And so if you look at the map of
saliency, black and white, you
can see
the peaks in the saliency map
correspond to peaks in the mass
map, which are concentrations of
matter, and these correspond to
galaxy clusters.
And this isn't news to
cosmologists.
We've known for decades that
galaxy clusters are a good way
of exploring cosmology. The
shapes of the features that this
network has learned are not
round balls, they are irregular
and they're showing some
structure.
And this is really interesting
to me. And there's also
indications that some of the
smaller mass concentrations are
showing up as important features
in this network.
And that's a little bit
unexpected. So by taking this
kind of introspection into the
features that our network is
learning we can start to learn
something about the data and get
insight into some of the
physical processes that are
going
on in our data, and learn what
kind of structures are most
sensitive to the interplay of
gravity and dark energy.
This is something that's a real
strong point of deep learning,
when you are allowing the
network to learn features for
itself rather than imposing
features, doing feature
engineering or  telling it any
particular statistics. You can
allow the network to tell you
something about your data that
might surprise you.
So far, that was looking at
two-dimensional maps, but, of
course the group verse is not a
two-dimensional place. It's at
least four dimensions, perhaps
many more dimensions depending
on your favorite model of string
theory.
But we've been looking at three
dimensions and scaling this  up.
The reason why three dimensions
are interesting for us, in a
three-dimensional data volume,
you're
looking at matrices,
convolutions, it's
computationally expensive and it
can run
really well on a supercomputing
architecture. A team recently
demonstrated for the first time
that deep learning can be used
to determine the physical model
of
the universe from
three-dimensional simulations of
the full matter distribution.
This is the full matter
rather than a two-dimensional
projection of the matter
density. And this work showed
that the network was able to
make significantly better
estimates of the parameters that
describe the physics of this
simulated universe compared to
traditional methods, where you
might be looking at one of these
statistics like the power
spectrum. And so this is a
really nice example of
how the network was able to
learn, and
what structures in this were
important rather than just
looking at statistics that we in
advance thought were going to be
useful.
So we're working on scaling
this up
in collaboration with NERSC, UC
Berkeley, Intel, and Cray.
We're using larger simulation
volumes, more data, and
TensorFlow running on
those of CPU nodes achieving
several petaflocks of data.
We're able to predict more
physical
parameters with even greater
accuracy by scaling up the
training. This is something
we're really excited about. I
think it's worth talking a
little bit more in technical
detail about how we achieved
this performance, how we are
using TensorFlow to get this
kind of performance and insight
into our data and our science.
Now, supercomputers are
fairly specialized.
We have  specialized hardware to
allow the tens of thousands of
compute nodes we have on these
computers to act together as one
compute machine. We want to use
this machine as efficiently as
possible to train our network.
We have a lot of performance
available to us. We want to be
able to take advantage of that
when we're  running TensorFlow.
The approach we take is using a
fully synchronous data parallel
approach where each node is
training on a subset of the
data.
And we started off as many
people do, using GRPC for this,
where each compute node is
communicating with a parameter
server to send their parameter
updates and have that sent back
and forward. But like many other
people have noted, this is not a
very efficient way to run at
scale. We found that if we were
running beyond a hundred nodes
or so, then we had a real
communication bottleneck between
the compute nodes and the
parameter servers.
So instead, we use NPI, which is
a message-passing interface to
allow our compute nodes to
communicate with each other
directly, removing the need for
parameter servers. And this also
has the advantage that you can
really take advantage of our
high-speed interconnect, the
specialized
hardware that connects our
compute nodes. So we use for
gradient aggregation for
this, we use a specialized NPI
collective, which is designed by
Cray, our partners with our
supercomputers.
And this MPI is pretty neat.
It's able to avoid imbalances in
the node performance, the
straggler effect that some of
you might run into. It's
overlapping communication and
compute in a way that allows
very effective scaling and we've
seen we're able to run
TensorFlow on thousands of nodes
with little drop in efficiency.
Something I've been excited to
see here
is MPI reduce is coming soon in
TensorFlow. And we're excited to
see how this is going to work in
the larger community.
So the three things I'd like you
to take away from this talk,
first, cosmology has cool
science problems and cool deep
learning problems. The second is
that scientific data is
different from natural image
data. The statistics that we
often have associated with
scientific data could be of real
use in the deep learning
community. And the third thing
is that MPI all reduce is the
optimal strategy for scaling
TensorFlow up to multiple nodes,
and we're looking forward to
seeing how the rest of the
community is going to work with
this.
So now I'll turn things back to
Lawrence. Thank you.
(Applause)
>> LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank
you, Debbie. Great stuff.
Actually simulating universes.
So, we're running very short on
time, so I just want to share,
these are just three great
stories. There are countless
more out there. This is a map
that I created of people
who starred TensorFlow and
GitHub and shared their
location. We have the people
from Australia to
Ireland, from the north arctic
circle in Norway all the way
down to deception island. There
are countless stories being
created and new things being
done with TensorFlow and machine
learning.
If some of those stories are
yours, we'd love to share them.
So with that, I just want to say
thank you very much for
attending today. Enjoy what's
left of I/O, and have a safe
journey home. Thank you.
(Applause)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Brand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exits. We'll be
making room for those who have
registered for the next session.
If you have registered for the
next session in this room, we
ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside. Thank you.
Android Fireside Chat
(Cheering and applause)
>> Hello, and welcome to the
Android fireside chat. We have a
lot of content. We're going to
get through that first and see
if we can get to questions next.
If we could get to the next
slide. I guess we're ready for
some questions. So we do have
one question to start off, if we
could go to that one. Someone
asked online on the Twitter
thread why is it called a
fireside chat if there's no
fire. I thought this was a
pretty good
question, so the answer to that
would be . . .
(Laughter)
(Applause)
>> MODERATOR: All right. So warm
yourselves by the fire. We're
going to ask some questions.
You're going to ask some
questions. We're going to try to
answer those questions. So, we
pre-rolled some questions
online. It was interesting to
see what people were thinking.
We have some of those. We'll
interweave them with questions
from the audience. I will show
you how that works in a
question. First, I'm Chet Haase,
Android toolkit team.
>> DAVE BURKE: Dave, most
things.
>> STEPHANIE SAAD:
>> I work on the developer
experience.
>> I work on Kotlin.
>> I manage the framework team.
>> I'm Xavier, I work on the
tools team.
>> CHET HAASE: We have a bunch
of other people from the
engineering team to my stage
right here. So if one of these
people here can
answer it, maybe one of the
people in the audience can't
answer, either. We have a couple
of questions to kick it off, and
then we'll kick it to the
audience. First of  all, what's
an exciting feature that you're
working on for the next release?
Romain, do you want to take that
one?
>> ROMAIN GUY: No.
>> CHET HAASE: That's a
really good example. We do not
answer questions about future
development, kind of a policy
thing that we have.
I would say 90% of the questions
I got on the Twitter thread were
about future development. That
makes it easy. We don't have to
answer those.
>> This is going really well.
>> CHET HAASE: We'll be done
in the next two minutes. Let's
ask a more real question. I'll
toss this to Romain.
Will Android architecture
components be a de facto
architecture choice with
continuous support, like
continuous builds except for
support.
>> ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
More seriously, we listened, you
were asking us to have an
opinion about architecture. For
many years we did not have one.
You can do whatever you want.
But we have a solution that's
our solution. We're going to
support it. We have tooling. We
have more libraries,
documentation, tons of talks. If
you like it or don't know what
architecture you want to use, go
with that one.
>> CHET HAASE: There you go.
That's an example. It was a real
question and kind of a real
answer as well. I would invite
everybody in the audience to ask
a question.
there are two microphones. We
were curious how long it would
take people to get to them.
It's going to be kind of a
Hunger Games thing. Come to the
mic, ask your question. If
people in the audience don't ask
questions, I have some here. I
see someone walking up. Go
ahead.
>> AUDIENCE: The mic is too
tall for me.
So, following up the question
about architecture components, I
remember Diane posting online
saying that, like, you know,
look, we gave you activity. We
gave you content, we gave you
all these things.
That's the agnostic platform,
you can
do whatever you want with it.
We're not going to impose any
choices on you. I'm sure there
are other people on the Android
team who agreed with her. I
wonder what Diane and those
other people might think about
architecture components. Is this
like a perversion of their
vision of Android?
(Laughter)
>> All wrong.
>> AUDIENCE: Or is this
something that like, I
understand why some people might
need it, but if you want to do
things weirdly, you can.
Was there a debate about
architecture components?
>> DIANNE HACKBORN: Basically,
that all holds true as far as
the core platform is concerned.
You can think of -- when I say
the framework team, it's the
Core platform. This is stuff
that's shipped on the device
that is, like, defines what you
can do with the device.
And we want to keep that still
generic,
not enforcing any particular
model. We want to have
flexibility for  applications to
do new things and all that kind
of stuff. The architecture
components are basically a layer
on top that it's very different,
because in the support library,
it can evolve rapidly with the
applications.
It can change and break because
it's not going to break
applications when those changes
happen. So we're basically
putting a new layer on top of
the platform that gives our
very strong position on how we
think applications should be
developed, which